فهو أيش يسوّي؟ يكلّم وزارة السياحة
فيه رقم للشكاوى، يقول أنا عندي مشكلة في شركة «المسافر» ويكلمونا
ونشرح لهم وكل شيء، ونحن ملتزمين
بالعكس نحترم الأنظمة وملتزمين فيها
في المقابل، لو حجز عن طريق أي منصة عالمية
وصار لها أي مشكلة؛ مالك قبيلي عندي
الجوف فيها أكبر مزرعة زيتون في العالم
أكبر بحيرة صناعية في العالم
موجودة في «دومة الجندل» اللي هي في الجوف
رحتها جميلة جدًّا بشكل مختلف
بالعكس تتعجب من الطبيعة الموجودة
فإذا صار فيها خدمات، السكان المحليين استغلوا الفرصة
تزامن هذا الشيء أنهم يسوون أكثر من حزمة لهم في «المسافر للأنشطة»
وللا الهيئة السعودية للسياحة سوّقت لهذا الموضوع
أعتقد فيه مجال للتطور بشكل كبير في الفترة القادمة
مثلًا نفترض أن الفندق عنده 500 غرفة
يقول أنت دائمًا متاح لك كل يوم خمس غرف، كأنها مؤكدة لك
وبفكها أنا قبل 24 ساعة من كل يوم
فدائمًا تلاحظ لما تبحث في كثير من المنصات يقولك
باقي غرفتين، باقي غرفة، باقي غرفتين
هو قد يكون هذا هو مخزونه الموجود
ثم إذا خلّص يكلمهم، يقول يلا افتحوا لي غرف زيادة، فيفتحون له زيادة
فيه شركات سفر وسياحة صغيرة موجودة في السعودية
يستهدف مناطق معينة، يستهدف وجهات معينة
مثلًا فيه مكتب سفر وسياحة بس متخصص في «موريشيوس»
ماسكها وعارف فنادقها من الألف إلى الياء
وعارف شركات السيارات اللي هناك
يقول أنا تخصصي «موريشيوس»
يلا حيّهم، حلقة اليوم بنغطي فيها قطاع مهم جدًّا في السعودية
وهو قطاع السياحة
القطاع ضخم، وفيه فرص كثيرة جدًّا
ممكن يستفيد منها الأفراد والشركات بمختلف أحجامها
لذلك استضفنا اليوم «فهد العبيلان»
الرئيس التنفيذي للسياحة في شركة «المسافر»
وهي أكبر منصة للسياحة والسفر في السعودية
بحيث يشاركنا تجاربهم وخبراتهم في هذا القطاع
على مدى السنوات الماضية
نتكلم بدايةً عن قصة «المسافر»
واستحواذ مجموعة «سيرا» عليها
وأيش التطورات والتغييرات اللي صارت في «المسافر» بعد الاستحواذ
ثم نتكلم عن جميع الخدمات اللي ممكن تستهدفها
شركات السياحة والسفر في رحلة «المسافر»
وهي خدمات كثيرة جدًّا بالمناسبة
ماهي محدودة بحجز التذاكر والفندق فقط
بنناقش أيضًا نموذج عمل شركات السياحة والسفر، وهوامش الربح فيها
كيف تتعامل مع الموردين؟
سواءً كان الموردين حجوزات حقين فنادق، طيران
كيف تتعامل مع الشركات السياحية في الخارج؟
كيف تتعامل مع الهيئات السياحية في الدول الثانية؟
وتفاصيل كثير في هذا النطاق
وطبعًا ما نقدر نسولف عن السياحة بدون ما نسولف عن السياحة الدينية
والفرص الكثير اللي تتيحها للشركات والأفراد
بالإضافة للسياحة الداخلية عمومًا
سواء كانت مرتبطة بالمشاريع السياحية مثل «العُلا» والبحر الأحمر
ومؤخرًا أُعلن عن قمم «السودة»
وفي برضه مشاريع كبيرة تهدف لدعم السياحة الداخلية
أو سياحة في المدن والمحافظات المحلية بشكل عام
حلقة ثرية جدًّا عن قطاع مهم جدًّا
أترككم معها الآن
حيّاك الله أخوي «فهد»
الله يحييك ويبقيك، هلا والله سهلا
أيش يسوي الرئيس التنفيذي للسياحة؟
عجبني المسمى، ولا أدري أيش تسوي صراحة
صحيح، يمكن هذه الوظيفة صارت بعد التحول
اللي صار في «المسافر» الفترة الأخيرة
أول كانت «المسافر» تركز على سفر الأفراد
اللي هو ناس يسافروا من نقطة ألف إلى نقطة باء
سواءً بخارج السعودية أو داخل السعودية
بس اليوم، الحمد لله، مع برامج الرؤية
اليوم السياحة الوافدة للسعودية تعتبر جزء أساسي
من المنظومة السياحية في المملكة العربية السعودية
ولا أقطع واردك، الوظيفة نفسها هذه
مستحدثة وللا هي موجودة في القطاع؟
هي موجودة في القطاع، يصير ناس موجودة
مثلًا في الهيئة السعودية للسياحة، تلقى واحد رئيس تنفيذي لسوق معينة
أنا الرئيس التنفيذي للسياحة، بحيث أن أي سياحة وافدة للسعودية
أنا مسؤول عنها وعن برامجها
سواءً من خلال السياحة الترفيهية
فهو رئيس قطاع، مو رئيس مثلًا نقول الرئيس التنفيذي للمبيعات
الرئيس التنفيذي للتسويق
هي مثل كذا، «المسافر» اليوم مقسمة لقسمين
فيه رئيس تنفيذي لقطاع السفر
وفيه رئيس تنفيذي للقطاع السياحي
قطاع السفر للناس يسافرون من ألف إلى باء، أو من 1 - 2
هذولا لا، الناس الوافدين
سواءً من خلال الحج والعمرة السياحة الدينية، أو السياحة الترفيهية
فهي قطاعات ماهي...
بالضبط ماهي أقسام
إيه، ماهي أقسام
رغم أن هي وظائف
فيه عندنا طبعًا زملاء، وشوي عندنا الهيكل التنظيمي متداخل
فيه عندنا وظائف أساسية وقطاعات، مثل القطاع اللي أنا ماسكه
وفيه رؤساء تنفيذين يخدمون كل القطاعات
إيه، الحين واضحة
تسافر واجد على كذا أتصور
والله على خفيف
كم تقريبًا؟ كم مرة تسافر في السنة؟
صراحة ما عديتها، بس السنة دي من أعلى السنوات في السفر
بحكم، الحمد لله، بعد كورونا صار فيه حراك كبير
سواءً للسياحة الجاية للسعودية
أو كذلك للناس اللي يبغون يروحون يسافرون برّا
بس أنت على المستوى الشخصي
تصدق مشهور أني ما قد عديتهم
بس يمكن أتوقع أكثر وحدة الحين بتسمع ذا الكلام زوجتي
لأنها دائمًا تقول وراك تسافر واجد
بس أعتقد يمكن أني سافرت ثلاثين مرة
إلى الآن في السنة هذه؟
في السنة هذه، تقريبًا حدود ثلاثين
سواءً داخل السعودية أو خارج السعودية
ما في لك إلا قوة أميال أجل معك، ما شاء الله
إيه والله على خفيف
أنا كنت أغبط كذا الناس اللي، ما شاء الله، يسافرون واجد في وظيفتهم
لين اشتغلت في وظيفة سابقة فيها سفر واجد
فيبدأ الموضوع يتحول لدوام أكثر من أنه...
100% أعتقد الموضوع يصير ممتع إذا صرت تسافر لبلدان كثيرة
توّي جاي مثلًا من الصين قبل أسبوعين، رحت إلى «شنقهاي»
مع أني قد رحت للصين قبل
بس لما تروح في مهمة، تقابل ناس من رجال أعمال هناك أو شركات
الموضوع مرة مختلف معهم
بس ما تحس سفرات العمل تحول السفر إلى...
تعرف إذا بتسافر سياحة تتذكر الدوام؟
إيه 100%
اللي تقولبها بشكل شغل، يصير أكثر من أنه...
لا، وفيه مشكلة في السفر حق الشغل؛ يخليك ما تشتغل
السفر تروح تخلص أمورك، بس الشغل المكتبي الشغل اليومي
اللي تشتغل فيه مع الفريق يتراكم عليك
وهذا صراحة اللي صاير معي
بس، الحمدلله، موفق بشباب ما يقصرون صراحة
يشيلون الشيلة إذا الواحد تسافر
إيه، ما شاء الله، إذا فيها بعد تنويع سفريات وكل شوي تسافر
لا، بس على فكرة، أحيانًا تصير مزعجة
ممكن أنت جربت، ترى موضوع ماهو دائمًا
السفر بكل الأحوال ممتع أصلًا، معروف على مر الزمان
السفر جزء من الترفيه
بس إذا كان مربوط بشغل، جيد أنك كيف تحول هذا الشيء
أنك تتعلم ونفس الفكرة تكون ترفّه عن نفسك
تحاول تغيّر جو
100%
مع أنك شطحت، واحد من أخوياي يقول أنك جربت أكل لحم تمساح!
عجيب! لحظة أنت تعرف أحد ما أعرفه أنا
والله يعني، يقول بالغلط، ما أدري إذا...
طبعًا هو شرعًا فيه فتوى، أنه يجوز أكل التمساح
حلو، نقدر نعتبره ضب كبير وللا؟
لا، هو فيه فتوى فيه
عشان يتقبلون الناس
كنت في جنوب أفريقيا كان 2010، ورحنا مطعم جنوب أفريقيا أذكر
فكان الطريق مثل المطاعم البرازيلية
يقدمون لك أنواع اللحم
ثم جيت أنا آكل، وذقت لحم، قلت أيش هو؟
لأن لحمة التمساح بيضاء، قريبة من الدجاج
أحس كل شيء يشبه الدجاج
إيه، بالضبط قريبة من الدجاج
فأكلتها، وقال لي وقال لي تدري أيش هذا؟ هذا تمساح
وقتها قلت شلون! دخلت على قوقل
وشفت فيه فتوى
فتوى أكل
إيه فتوى للشيخ «عبدالعزيز بن باز» والشيخ «ابن عثيمين»مفتين فيها
موجودة، حتى تقدر تبحث عنها
ففعلًا أكلت منه
تفاجأت من ذي، ترى جبنا سوالف ثانية بعد
بس ما حبيتها شاطحة شوي
خلنا على هذه ويكفي
نخليها لنهاية الحلقة
صحيح لا يضر
قبل ما نبدأ في موضوع
أيش سوّى «المسافر» والأشياء اللي داخلين فيها؟
ودي تعطينا نبدة عن تأسيس «المسافر» إلى اليوم
أنا حاولت على الفكرة استضيف «فاروق الجريسي» سابقًا
إيه والنعم
ما رضى، «فاروق» إذا تتابعني ترى إلى الحين أبغاك تطلع في البرنامج
انشغل هو طبعًا بمشاريع ثانية
بس ودي تعلمني السالفة باختصار
من يوم بدأ التأسيس مع «فاروق الجريسي» إلى الاستحواذ اللي صار
وبعدين اللي صاير اليوم
أعتقد أن قصة «المسافر» قصة فريدة صراحة
تزامنت مع أكثر من عمل، ولكن كما ذكرت
الله يذكره بالخير أخونا «فاروق الجريسي»
بدأ بقصة «المسافر» كحساب في وسائل التواصل
يخدم رغبات الناس
في السفر والسياحة؟
في السفر والسياحة، حجزات الفنادق فقط
ما كان عنده طيران
وكان الهدف أنه يغطي فاقد موجود بالسوق
كان في 2012 وقبل، مو أي أحد عنده بطاقة ائتمانية
وكذلك مو كل المواقع تقدر تتعامل مع السعوديين من ناحية سفرهم
اليوم لو شفنا السعوديين وين بيسافرون
ترى هي قاعدة 20/80
تلقى فيه خمسة عشر وجهة هي 80% من الشعب يسافر لها
فيه ناس يسافرون إلى مناطق غير الخمسة عشر هذه
بس على سبيل المثال، دبي، البحرين، إسطنبول، القاهرة، لندن، باريس
وهذه يمكن هي البلدان اللي الأغلب يسافرون لها السعوديين
المالديف، قريبًا صارت تايلند
ولكن اللي أقصده أنه ركز على هذولي
حاول أن يصير المحتوى محلي جدًّا، فتدخل على موقع
بعدين سوى طبعًا التطبيق، ففيه اللغات
كمستوى محلي قصدك؟
مالك لوا، حاول أنه يخلي اللغة تتناسب مع السعوديين
من ناحية الكلام الموجود
قصدك المحتوى في النصوص وللا إيه؟
النصوص وكذلك الصور، المناطق اللي يحبون يروحون لها
مثلًا لندن بلد مرة كبيرة
ولكن معروف الخليجيين والسعوديين يحبون وين يسكنون
فيحاول يركز عليها
على الشوارع
بالضبط، فحاول يركز على أن يكون المحتوى كمخزون للفنادق
يكون يغطي الفئة هذه
الشيء الثاني، كان اشتهر «المسافر» أول ما بدأ، بأنه احجز وادفع بعدين
هذا الموضوع لأنه كان يستخدم البطاقة ائتمان حق شركة «المسافر»
تجي أنت تحجز، يقول احجز الحين
وقبل السفرة بخمسة أيام أو أسبوع
على حسب اتفاقيته مع المورد أو كذلك الفندق
يتمم الحجز، بحيث أنه يسوي حوالة
كان «المسافر» يحجز نيابة عن العميل
نعم
يعني يدفع
يقول للي بيدفع أو يسوي حظر للبطاقة الائتمانية
فغطى هذا الجانب بشكل مرة كبير
بالإضافة للمحتوى اللي ذكرناه قبل شوي
فبدأت القصة، القصة مرة جميلة
بدأوا وكانوا سبع موظفين، كبر الفريق وكبر
تزامن هذا الشيء مع استثمارات المجموعة
كانت مجموعة «الطيار» سابقًا، اليوم اسمها مجموعة «سيرا»
ما شاء الله، لها أكثر من أربعين سنة في السوق
عندها علاقات مع جميع الموردين في العالم
وطبعًا كانت أقدر أقول الأسلوب العادي
في التعاطي مع السفر والسياحة في وقتها
كان مكتب سفر وسياحة، تدخل تقول أبي التذكرة الفلانية
أبي أحجز فندق
فيه موظف خاص بالتذاكر، موظف خاص...
تقليدي يعني
تقليدي نعم
تزامن هذا الشيء مع أن «الطيار» تبغى تستثمر في منصة سفر
فأسسوا وقتها منصة اسمها «تجوّل»
وكانت موجودة كمبرمجين وناس في الإمارات
أسسوا هذا الموضوع
وقتها طلعت الـ«مسافر» فكان مجلس الإدارة في ذاك الوقت
قرر أن يستحوذ على جزء من «المسافر»
وبدأ النقاش مع «فاروق الجريسي»
في 2015 جات إدارة تنفيذية جديدة للمجموعة
الله يذكره بالخير كان «عبدالله الداود»
هو الرئيس التنفيذي للمجموعة ذاك الوقت
وكان برضه فيه مجلس إدارة موجود برئاسة المهندس «محمد الخليل»
مع جميع أعضاء المجلس في ذاك الوقت
كيف نقدر نطور الموضوع
ونبعد «تجوّل» في ذاك الوقت، وبعده مع «المسافر»
أنها ما تكون ترتبط بالعمل التقليدي الموجود
فكانوا فريق منفصل من ناحية المبرمجين
والناس اللي يفهمون في تجربة العميل، واللي لهم علاقة
منفصلين تمام الانفصال عن أعمال المجموعة، ما لهم علاقة
عشان ما يكون عندهم إزعاج
هم الحين جابوا «تجوّل» و«المسافر» وللا؟
إيه نعم، اللي صار بعدين طال عمرك
تزامن هذا أيضًا مع إطلاق رؤية 2030
صار القطاع السياحي هو القطاع الثاني
من ناحية المساهمة في الناتج المحلي
سواءً في قطاع الحج والعمرة وقطاع السياحة الوافدة
بالإضافة كان سوق السفر في السعودية تقريبًا حدود 60 مليار
وكنا احنا الشركة الأكبر في السوق، في سوق الشرق الأوسط حتى
ليس فقط في السوق السعودي
وكان تقريبًا نجيب 4- 3 مليار بالحدود ذي
ففيه فاقد مرة كبير
إذا طورت أمورك وبعدت عن المشروع التقليدي
تقدر تتطور أن تكون متزامن
أُطلق برنامج...
أيش يعني متزامن؟
متزامن مع الرؤية
حلو
ومتواكب معها
في 2017 عظمة الإدارة في المجموعة أطلقوا برنامج للتحول
وهذا طبعًا كان بإثراء من الرؤية اللي أُطلقت في 2016
برنامج التحول طبعًا كان فيه تحول «المسافر»
نتج عنه أن اندمجت «المسافر» مع «تجوّل»
صارت هي وحدة سفر الأفراد في المجموعة
كذلك نستفيد من العلاقات الموجودة مع الموردين العالميين الموجودين
اللي يتعامل معهم «الطيار»
وكذلك اللي كوّنها «المسافر» في الفترة الأخيرة
استفدنا من تجربتنا في تطوير العديد من البرامج
أو الأنظمة الرقمية الموجودة، سواءً نظام الحجز
أو محرك البحث أو الحل اللي لما تدخل طلبك
هو اللي يبحث في كثير من المنصات، يجيب لك أفضل سعر
بالإضافة اللي سوّت بعد قفزة جميلة جدًّا
أننا دخلنا الطيران من ضمن المنتجات
اللي احنا نبيعها في «المسافر» في 2017
فكانت تحجز الطيران من خلال «المسافر» وكذلك تحجز الفنادق
الحمد لله، صار فيه تطور مرة كبير
2019 أُطلق برنامج التحول، أُعلن عنه
تغير اسم المجموعة لـ «مجموعة سيرا القابضة»
وكذلك أُعلن عن جميع العلامات التجارية في ذلك الوقت
والحمد لله، اليوم استمر الموضوع في النمو بشكل مرة كبير
2012 كانت «المسافر» مبيعات صفرية
ما تتجاوز 3 مليون تقريبًا
الحمد لله، السنة الماضية قفلنا 6.2 مليار
ونطمح السنة هذه أن نصل إلى 8 مليار بإذن الله
يمكن نتكلم عن الأرقام بشكل أكبر
بس هذا التحول الموجود
صح أنه كان في فترة كورونا، وأثّرت بشكل مرة كبير على الشركة
بس تعلمنا منها بشكل مرة كبير
يمكن شلنا كثير من التكدس الموجود
أو أقدر أقول، الشيء اللي قد يثقّل عملنا
ودمجنا كثير من وحدات الأعمال الموجودة
وبرضه جاكم عرض استحواذ من صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
نعم هذه في 2021 بعد كورونا
يمكن بدأ النقاش في الموضوع
وأٌعلن عن اتفاقية غير ملزمة للطرفين
بين شركة «المسافر» وصندوق الاستثمارات العامة
الاتفاقية تقول قُيم «المسافر» تقريبًا بحدود مليار دولار، أي 3.750 مليار
وصندوق الاستثمارات العامة بياخذ 30% من «المسافر»
ولكن أيش هي «المسافر»؟
ما هي فقط وحدة سفر للأفراد
اليوم «المسافر» تحولت أنها صارت وحدة سفر الأفراد
اللي هي التطبيق، والتطور اللي صار فيه
من خلال الفروع، من خلال فروع المطارات
وخلال مركز الاتصال وخدمة الواتساب
هذا اللي يختص بسفر الأفراد
اللي يشكل العمود الفقري للشركة من ناحية التطور
كذلك عندنا وحدة «المسافر أعمال»
«المسافر أعمال» هي حلول سفر للقطاع الحكومي والشركات
عندنا حسابات كثيرة جدًّا ماسكينها
حساب وزارة الصحة مثلًا، تديره شركة «المسافر»
ووزارة الثقافة، كثير من شركات الـ«بي آي إف» احنا الآن نديرها
كثير من المستشفيات العسكرية، برضه احنا اللي نديرها
والحمد لله، نعمل بالتزامن مع الخطوط السعودية بشكل مرة كبير
نوفر أفضل تجربة للمسافرين من خلال القطاع الحكومي
وكذلك الشركات الكبيرة الموجودة في السعودية
الشركة الثالثة اللي أُطلقت في آواخر 2019
سميناها شركة «اكتشف السعودية» اللي هي شركة إدارة وجهات
وهذا المصطلح موجود يسمونه «دي إم سي»
وهذه بندخل نفصلها أكثر، كفرص في السوق للناس المهتمين
والقطاعات هذه، بس أنا مهتم الحين نسولف أكثر عن المشروع حقكم
ولأن أنت سألتني قبل بداية الحلقة
استخدمت «المسافر» قبل ذلك وللا لا؟
صحيح، أنت استخدمته وللا لا؟
دقيقة، ولا صار عندنا فرصة نناقش الموضوع
ما قد استخدمته صراحة قبل كذا
أبدًا؟
قد دخلت، بحثت ودورت
يمكن أني حجزت مرة من خلاله
بس الإشكالية اللي أواجهها إجمالًا مع منصات السفر والسياحة
أني ما أحس أن فيه فرق بينهم
حتى المنصات العالمية
المزايا تصير مرة موجودة ومرة مو موجودة
على فكرة «المسافر» راح للعالمية
فلا تقول العالمية واحنا بس لا
لا أقصد الأجنبية
أعتمد بشكل كبير على المنصات الأجنبية في حجوزات الفنادق
وإذا بغيت أحجز على الخطوط، أروح على الخطوط مباشرة احجز عندهم
قد يكون جهلًا مني، ما أعرف أيش القيمة اللي تقدمها المنصات المختلفة
فيمكن هذا إجابةً على سؤالك
من وجه نظرك، أيش القيمة اللي ممكن تقدمها
إذا كل أحد ثاني يقدم نفس الخدمات؟
ممتاز، يمكن أن ذكرت واحدة من الأشياء
اللي تختلف في القطاع هذا عن أي قطاع آخر
لو جينا إلى الخدمة الأساسية اللي نبيعها
احنا نبيع طيران، أنا أتكلم الحين عن سفر الأفراد
اللي هي أساس «المسافر» أول ما بدأ
احنا نبيع كرسي طيارة وغرفة فندق
متاحة لعشرة آلاف واحد يقدر يبيعها غيرنا
و لا نأثر على التجربة، ولكن احنا ننظر لتجربة المسافر
من يوم ما يبدأ يفكر يسافر إلى أن يرجع من السفر
سلسلة القيمة الموجودة هذه من يوم يفكر الشخص
إلى أن يسافر ويرجع
فيها خطوات كثيرة قد يحتاجنا فيها العميل
وهذا مصدر قوة «المسافر»
خلني أدخل بالتفصيل، التحول اللي صار في عام 2019
بعد ما أطلقنا برنامج التحول
قد يكون أفضل لو ناخذها كخدمة خدمة في السلسلة هذه
على أساس حتى المستمع اللي مهتم
لأني متأكد كل خطوة، فيها فرص ممكن واحد يبدأ فيها مشروع
100%
أو واحد يبدأ فيها مشروع متخصص في القطاع
أيش الخطوات الموجودة في السلسلة هذه كلها؟
أول شيء، أني أجذب العميل أن يسافر
أني أقدر أعلن من خلال أي منصة في وسائل التواصل
من خلال إذا بحث، من خلال إذا تكلمنا اليوم وسولفنا
يمكن لو تفتح يوتيوب الحين يطلع لك إعلان «المسافر»
لا، أنا قصدي كخدمات
هذه بحد ذاتها خدمة، احنا ننظر لها هذه على أنه خدمة
أني أقول للعميل ترى أنا موجود. فهذه هي نظرتنا للعميل
وهذا طبعًا تم بناءً على دراسات سويناها لما جلسنا مع العملاء
قالنا أيش اللي يريحك لما تجي تسافر؟ أيش أهم شيء يريحك؟
قال ودي كل ما فكرت أسافر، أو بأي طريقة كانت
أقدر أتعامل مع جهة معينة تقدر تخدمني
فعشان كذا سوينا مصطلح جديد ممكن أول شركة سفر
موجودة في المنطقة طبقت مبدأ اسمه القنوات تفاعلية
أو نموذج عمل اسمه القنوات التفاعلية
فيه شركات تقدم الخدمة من خلال قناة وحدة
يقول أنا مثلًا عندي تطبيق
وفيه شركات عندها أكثر من قناة، فعندها قنوات متعددة للخدمة
عندها تطبيق، وعندها مركز اتصال، وعندها فرع
احنا اليوم نقدم الخدمات من خلال قنوات تفاعلية
أيش الفرق بين قنوات متعددة وقنوات تفاعلية؟
اللي يسمونها القنوات تفاعلية
القنوات التفاعلية أن عندي فرع، وعندي كونتر في المطار
وعندي مركز اتصال، وعندي خدمة واتساب أقدر أحجز منها كاملةً
أسوي التجربة كاملة، وعندي كذلك التطبيق أو موقع إلكتروني
جميع هذه تاخذ البيانات من مكان واحد
والمخزون حق الفنادق والطيران من مكان واحد
والأسعار وحدة والحملات وحدة
حتى لما تتعامل مع أي قناة، وتروح لأي قناة ثانية
نعرف أنك دخلت فيها
فعلى سبيل المثال، لو دخلت على التطبيق وبحثت يا مشهور
وكنت مسجل بالإيميل حقك وللا شيء
لما تروح للفرع، يدخل اسمك، رقم جوالك
يبان عنده أنك بحثت عندنا قبل
وأنك بحثت عن مثلًا، بتسافر دبي أو القاهرة، فبحثت
فيبان هذا الموضوع، فنبني قاعدة بيانات مرة ممتازة
بس هذه يمكن طريقة خدمة عملاؤكم
نعم
بس ماهي خدمات سياحة وسفر
لأني كان أقصد الخدمات التي تقدمونها
بدايةً من رغبة العميل بالسفر إلى أن يرجع مرة ثانية
فيه مجموعة خدمات هنا، نقدر نؤسس شركات عليها
100%
شكرًا، فأيش هي الخدمات هذه اللي عندك؟
حجز تذكرة حق السفر
حجز تذكرة، حجز فندق
أنا ليش أقول لك القنوات؟ عشان أقولك
من الخدمات اللي موجودة أننا نقدم معلومات ممتازة عن الوجهات
لو تدخل موقع «المسافر» فيه معلومات ممتازة جدًّا
عن أي مدينة يسافرون لها، اللي بيسافرون عن طريق «المسافر»
في وحدة مثلًا من الأفكار أني أقدم خطة سفر
لأي شخص وأقدر أبيعها مثلًا
وهذا موجود ترى، اليوم بدت شركات تسوي هذا الشيء
تجهيز خطط سفر
نعم، أنت وعائلتك بتسافرون لأوربا، تقول ودي أروح
طيب أروح لسويسرا وللا أروح...
فبعضهم يدخل مواقع إنترنت ويشوف
تخيل واحد يجي يقدم لي ويقول لك
تروح تسافر عن طريق الخطوط الفلانية
أول ثلاثة أيام تروح المدينة الفلانية، ثم تنتقل المدينة الفلانية
في المدينة الفلانية يحجز في الفندق الفلاني، وهذه بالفندق الفلاني
وإذا رحت المنطقة هذه روح للمكان هذا
وشوف البحر هذا وشوف الميدان هذا
فهذه المعلومات تعتبر جدًّا ممتازة
مو بأي واحد يقدر يحصل عليها، ولا يقدر واحد ياخذ منها الخبرة
والحمد لله، اليوم هذه يقدمها «المسافر» موجودة
تجهيز خطط سفر
تجهيز خطط سفر من خلال مستشارين سفر
الشيء الثاني، موضوع الطيران
قبل شوي كنا نتكلم، تقول أنا ما أحجز إلا أروح لموقع الخطوط
احنا اليوم، الحمد لله، تعاملنا مع أكبر...
عندنا تعامل مع أكثر من 450 شركة طيران في العالم
ولكن برضه الخطوط اللي تجي لدول الخليج
لأن اليوم احنا متواجدين في السعودية وفي دول الخليج أيضًا
عندنا تعاملات معهم، وعندنا حلول تقنية تضمن لك السعر المناسب
وبرضه نقدم لك خدمة، أنك مثلًا لما تحجز عن طريق الخطوط السعودية
لنفترض بتروح لمصر مثلًا القاهرة، ثم من القاهرة بتروح لدولة أخرى
احنا نقدم لك الحل هذا كاملًا، من خلال أكثر من خطوط
ليس من خطوط وحدة
فهذا الشيء يعطيك أريحية في التعامل مع شخص واحد
بدل ما تتعامل مع أكثر من شخص
الشيء الثاني، عندنا برامج ولاء جدًّا ممتازة
سواءً مشاركتنا مع البنوك، سواء شراكتنا مع برامج الولاء
مثلًا «قطاف» وللا «الفرسان»
إذا حجزت عن طريق «المسافر» بيجيك نقاط معينة
تستفيد منها في أي حجوزات مستقبلية
قد تكون هذه ماهي موجودة في شركات أخرى
وهذا اللي يميز «المسافر» في أن العملاء مستمرين معه
تجيه النقاط في «المسافر» وفي «الفرسان»؟
نعم
في كلا المنصتين؟
نعم، طبعًا مثلًا إذا اليوم عندنا شراكة
مع برنامج «الفرسان» في الخطوط السعودية
يقول لك إذا جيت تشتري، بعدين يجيك خيار
تقدر تاخذ مقابل شراءك نقاط في «الفرسان»
أو تأخذ نقاط في «قطاف» أو تأخذ استرداد نقود
أو أي وسيلة على حسب الحملة الموجودة
فهذه مثل البرامج
خلنا نقول، الخدمة هذه أنك تقدر تسوي خطة السفر للعميل
بغض النظر عن الخطوط اللي يستخدمها
صحيح
أيضًا الظاهر دخلتوا في حجز الشاليهات بعد قبل فترة
إيه نعم، وهذا جزء من البرنامج اللي صار من برامج الرؤية
تعرف المملكة، اللهم لك الحمد، فتحت أبوابها في آخر 2019
بعد الإعلان عن الفيزا السياحية
بالإضافة صار فيه حراك كبير جدًّا من قبل هيئة السعودية للسياحة
لإبراز العديد من الوجهات داخل السعودية
سواءً للسكان المحليين السعوديين أو المقيمين في السعودية
أو اللي بيجون من برّا السعودية
طبعًا هذا تم من خلال تفعيل المواسم في السعودية
موسم الرياض، موسم الشرقية قبل، موسم جدة، الآن موسم عسير
أيش علاقتها بالشاليهات؟
أنا أقولك
ما شاء الله عليك، أنت عجل مشهور
لا، بس لأن النقطة أبغى أطب عليها على طول
في كثير من الوجهات
فيها مشكلة في عدم وفرة الفنادق اللي تسد الطلب
احنا تعاقدنا مع كثير من الشاليهات أو المزارع أو المخيمات
وتكون تتناسب مع مستوى الخدمة اللي نبغى نعطيه عملاءنا
فيقدر الواحد يسافر لـ«العُلا» يسافر للطائف، يسافر للجنوب
وبرضه يجي للرياض ويقدر يسكن في شاليه
فهذا يخدم المنظومة السياحية بشكل عام
أن يكون فيه حلول أخرى للسكن غير الفنادق أو الشقق المفروشة
فيه بعد عندكم خدمات مواصلات
اللي يمكن ثار انتباهي فيها خدمة طيارات خاصة؟
طبعًا فيه عندنا قسم في «المسافر» اسمه «المسافر كونسيرج»
هذا طبعًا يقدم خدمات أقدر أقول أنها فاخرة
لفئة معينة من العملاء، بحيث يبغي يأخذ طيارة خاصة
أو كذلك على مستوى القطاع الحكومي أو الشركات
فيه شركات أحيانًا تطلب طيارة خاصة تبغى تسافر
احنا مثلًا من الناس اللي فعّلنا هذا الموضوع وقت كورونا
تذكر أيام وقت كورونا كانت فيه طيارات إجلاء
لكثير من الجنسيات اللي عايشة في السعودية
وكانوا مو عارفين متى يرجع الشغل
فكثير منهم طلب أن يسافر خارج السعودية
ولا كانن فيه رحلات مجدولة من قبل رحلات الطيران
احنا من شركة «المسافر» كنا من أوائل الشركات
اللي جدولنا مثل هذه الرحلات الخاصة لمصر، للسودان
وسويناها بشكل مرة كبير
بالإضافة كخدمة فاخرة، احنا أكبر مشغل
أو أقدر أقول نبيع طيارات خاصة في المنطقة
الطيارات الخاصة تكون تابعة للشركات وللا الخطوط وللا؟
مثل الخطوط السعودية عندهم شركة «إس بي إيه»
نستأجر منهم طيارات، أو فيه شركات خاصة موجودة في العالم
ما شاء الله، يعرضوا خدماتهم
والشركات هذه تتيح لأي أحد عنده منصة أن يشبك معها مثل الفنادق
غالبًا هذه ما يصير شبك معها، غالبًا تصير أوفلاين
تصير من خلال اتفاقية تجارية معينة، نطلب منهم الطيارة
ثم إذا رغب العميل نرتبها
بس أقدر أنا كواحد بيسوي مشروع تأجير طيارات خاصة مثلًا
أقدر أتعامل معهم وأصير أنا وسيط؟
100% واليوم فيه شركات كبيرة في السوق
وأتوقع صار فيه فرص مرة ممتازة وقت كورونا
فيه كثير، ما شاء الله، اقتنص الفرص هذه
واشترى طيارات بأسعار جدًّا زهيدة
واليوم صار يشغلها طيران خاص
من اللي اشتراها؟
تجار
طيارات خاصة؟
طيارات خاصة، واليوم سوى له أسعار وصار يأجرها
لقطة، أخذها تلقاها بأقل سعر
الناس الفخمين مثلك يمكن مناسب أنهم يستأجرون
لا، أنا ما عمري أصلًا ركبت طيارة خاصة في حياتي
إلا إذا كان بتسفروني بعد الحلقة
ما قد جربتها ولا أدري عن تفاصيلها
عشان كذا يمكن كن هي أكثر شيء
موجودة عندنا الخدمة هذه
كم تكلّف تقريبًا؟
طبعًا على حسب، تعرف الطيران الخاص
أنا لو بقط مع شباب الاستراحة ونروح
فعلًا مثلًا فيه وجهات في أوربا
تقدر تسافر من نقطة إلى نقطة أخرى
أحيانًا تصير قريبة من سعر الدرجة الأولى، يمكن يزود 30%
ففيه ناس كثيرين يسوونها
يقول مثلًا بسافر من لندن إلى «كان»
فتلقاه يسافر على طيارة، خاصة تلقى أعلى منها
وفي شركات أوربية كثيرة احنا عندنا تعامل معهم
نقدر نرتب هذا الشيء
ولكن لها أكثر من جانب عشان يتحدد السعر
هل هي بتروح مليانة ثم ترجع فاضية؟
طبعًا هذا أنك تدفع الذهاب والعودة
أوه صح، لأنك أنت اللي مطيّرها
أنت اللي مطيّرها، فأنت جاي
دحين كثير من الشركات الطيران يصير عنده رحلة رايحة مليانة
فيحاول أن يروّج أو يحاول يعرض الطيارة فاضية
بأسعار جدًّا ممتازة، فتجي فاضية
ولكن تختلف على حسب قيمة الأرضية والوقوف
فيه بعضهم يقول بروح ثلاثة أيام مثلًا
وأبغى الطيارة تكون واقفة تنتظرني ما ترجع
فهذه طبعًا لها تكلفة في إيجار الأرضية
ومتى ما خلصت أدق على الطيار، أقول حمِّ الطيارة أنا جاي
بالضبط، فهذا الشيء موجود
والحمد لله، اليوم سواءً مع كثير من الجهات الحكومية
كثير من الفعاليات اللي تصير في السعودية
قمنا بتشغيل كثير من الطيارات الخاصة
اللي نسويها مع كثير من الجهات الحكومية، الحمد لله
نفس مشكلة الدينّات، إذا راح مكان يبي يضمن أن في حمولة راجعة
عشان يقدر يستغل
أمثلتك زينة والله مرة
هذا أقرب شيء
قصيمي أنت وللا لا؟
إيه، بس هذا أقرب شيء، ماهو مع سطحة، مع دينّات
فيه برضه خدمات الترحيب والاستقبال، الظاهر كأني سمعت
نعم، هذه تتم من خلال إذا فيه واحد بيسافر من السعودية
إلى أي بلد خارج السعودية
عندنا علاقات مع كثير من الموردين
فتقدر من يوم تطلع من باب الطيارة
فيه شركات موجودة في كثير من بلدان العالم
الموردين هذولي أيش يسوون؟
خلاص يقدم الخدمة لي أنا
كأن أنت جاي عن طريق «المسافر» فيستقبلك في المطار
احنا عندنا تواصل
أيش طبيعة الأشياء اللي يقدمونها؟
هل بس يمسك لوحة ويستقبلك ويوديك الفندق؟
يستقبلك في المطار، ياخذ جوازك، يعلمك الإجراءات
يتأكد أن عفشك وصل، ثم يرتب مع السواق أنك خلاص توصل
فهذا استقبال وتوصيل
هذا نطاق خدمتهم
فيه بعض المطارات على حسب البنية التحتية في المطارات
فيه بعض المطارات هم جايبين شركات تسوي الخدمة هذه
فيصير فيه صالات داخل المطارات
فتدخل تجلس في صالة، يخلصون إجراءاتك بالكامل، ثم بعدين تطلع
اليوم، الحمد لله، ممكن هذا في مسافرينا سواءً من السعودية
أو من الكويت وللا من أي دول الخليج، أنهم يسافرون برّا
ولكن الوافدين للسعودية، عندنا شركة «التنفيذي» تسوي هذا الخدمة
ولها اشتراكات معينة
واحنا نقدم الخدمة هذه وموقعين شراكة استراتيجية معاهم
فيه الظاهر بس السعودية
اللي يجي للسعودية
أو الظاهر حتى ثلاث مطارات، لا عفوًا...
إلى ثمانية وعشرين مطار، شوف ما أحد يعرف
بس اليوم وقعنا معهم شراكة لترويج الخدمة هذه
لأي أحد بيجي للسعودية، ولكن فيها...
«التنفيذي» فيه ثمانية وعشرين مطار؟
فيه ثمانية وعشرين مطار في السعودية
أو خليني أقول في أغلب مطارات السعودية فيه صالة لـ«التنفيذي»
صالة «التنفيذي» للي ما يعرفونها، اللي هي تروح في صالة خاصة
نعم
يوصّلون بسيارة الظاهر؟
صحيح بالسيارة، ويخلصون إجراءاتك ويجيبون الشنط حقك
وقعنا معهم شراكة، والآن نعمل معهم في هذا الموضوع
لترويج الخدمة للناس القادمين من خارج السعودية
من خلال شركة إدارة الوجهات اللي تملكها «المسافر»
فالشيء اللي أقصد، أنت سألتني أيش أوجه المشروع
أتوقع هذا مشروع جدًّا ممتاز
وأتوقع الفترة القادمة هيئة الطيران المدني
إيه، خدمة الترحيب
وأعتقد فيه فرصة ممتازة لإثراء التجربة للي جاء من برّا السعودية
مثلًا فيه كثير من بلدان العالم، أول ما تطلع من باب الطيارة
فيه واحد يقدر يستقبلك
احنا إلى اليوم ما وصلنا للمرحلة هذه في السعودية
بسبب أن لسه فيه إجراءات معينة أمنية لازم تصير
فتلقاهم ما يستقبلونك إلا بعد الجوازات
أو بعد العفش بالأصح
أعتقد اليوم فيه حراك من قبل الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
من قبل هيئة الطيران المدني لتعزيز التجربة هذه
بحيث أن يكون فيه واحد يستقبلك من يوم ما تطلع من الطيارة
وهذا مجال كبير للقطاع الخاص
فعلًا فيه فرص كبيرة لقطاع السياحة
أنا أذكر إذا ماني بغلطان فيه واحد مر علي
عنده شركة متخصصة فقط في المواصلات للسياح
يستقبل السياح، عنده سيارات، يستقبلهم يوصلهم
يدير موضوع المواصلات بالنسبة لهم فقط
وما شاء الله، كبرت الشركة عنده وأموره تمام
كل خطوة في رحلة العميل فيها فرص
لو واحد بيقدم فيها خدمات
100%
فيه موضوع التأشيرات برضه، أنتم شغالين فيها برضه صح؟
إيه، احنا عندنا نقدم تأشيرات
واليوم، الحمد لله، مع العلاقات الدبلوماسية
اللي قاعدة تترتب بشكل كبير بين السعودية وبين الدول
كل ما له هذا الموضوع قاعد يقل
أنت تعرف، من أول كان عشان تحصل على تأشيرة صعب جدًّا
كثير من البلدان، على سبيل المثال بريطانيا
كان أول لازم تروح للسفارة وتروح للمكتب
اليوم لا، صارت عبر الإنترنت
عشر دقائق
بالضبط، نفس الفكرة اليابان صارت في هذا الموضوع
سنقافورة بدأوا في هذا الموضوع
فهذا المشروع ممتاز، ولكنه قاعد يقل للسعوديين
بس تعرف اليوم السعودية فاتحة أبوابها
فقد يكون فيه جنسيات أخرى مستقبلًا تجي للسعودية، فتحتاج هذا الخدمة
فهذا برضه مجال احنا مركزين فيه
خدمة في التأشيرات السعودية قصدك
التأشيرات السعودية، أو لا واحد مقيم في السعودية
يبغي يسافر لأي بلد في العالم، فيحتاج أحد يطلع له فيزا
ما يكون سعودي
إيه، ما يكون سعودي
لأننا خففنا إجراءات القدوم للأجانب
فهم يخففون برضه إجراءات الذهاب
100%
فهذه ممتازة، إن شاء الله، هذا هو المشروع
اللي تتمنى أنه ما يكمل، لأن فعلًا نبغى تخف إجراءات التأشيرات
هذولي برضه موردين وللا السفارات مباشرةً تعملون معهم؟
هذا لا، عن طريق السفارات، بس عندنا قسم كامل للتأشيرات
يرتب هذه الإجراءات، سواءً للمسافرين عن طريق القطاع الحكومي
أو كذلك الأفراد
والسفارات تاخذها، يعني تعرف أنها تعمل مع مشروع تجاري؟
وللا كأنه فرد يجي يقدّم على الخطوط؟
لا، طبعًا السفارات غالبًا متعاقدين مع مكتب لإنهاء التأشيرات
بعض السفارات لازم تروح لهم مباشرة
وبعض السفارات لا، عن طريق مكتب التأشيرات
فيه نوعية من العملاء
لو أن الإجراءات عبر الإنترنت فيبغى أحد يساعده
ما زال فيه موجود النوعية هذه
بحيث يقول لك أنا هذه معلوماتي
أنت خلّص لي الإجراءات من الألف للياء
احنا بعد برضه نرتب الخدمة هذه
حتى بعض إجراءات استخراج التأشيرات
من بعض الدول تكون عبر الإنترنت، أنت تقدر تطلعها بنفسك
بعض العملاء يقول لا، أبغاكم أنتم تساعدوني فيها
وهذه موضوع مصطلح «مستشار السفر»
أن احنا نخدمك في عملية السفر من الألف للياء
فأنتم عندكم كل الخدمات
في كل خدمة فيه مجموعة من الموردين تتعاملون معهم
بس بالنسبة للعميل هو يتعامل مع منصة وحدة
بالضبط
وتكون واجهة للموردين هذول كلهم المجتمعين
وأرجع للموضوع الأول، تقول أيش اللي يخلينا نمسك تجربة العميل
من يوم ما يبدأ...
بس قبل ما تجي للنقطة ذي، هم كلهم نموذج عمل واحد
اللي أنت تاخذ تكلفة الخدمة وتضيف عليها نسبة
نعم، وأحيانًا تصير لها عمولة
تصير سعرها ثابت للجميع، بس أنا لي عمولة
كيف يعني؟
الحين مثلًا سعرها نفترض 100 ريال، التكلفة علي
وأنا أبيعها للعميل 115، لنفترض جدلًا
أو يصير سعرها واضح في السوق أنها 100 ريال لكل الناس
ولك نسبة منها
لي أنا نسبة منها، فيصير أعطيه
فيا تضيف أنت ربحك، أو أنك تاخذ
على حسب الاتفاقية اللي تصير مع مقدم الخدمة
حسب الاتفاقية
حسب الاتفاقية نعم
أيش الدارج أكثر في قطاع السياحة؟
يختلف والله، ما في قاعدة واحدة على حسب
يا تصير بنظام العمولة أو أنها تصير أني أضيف عليها السعر حقي
طبعًا في الفنادق أكيد أنك تضيف السعر حقك
وهنا مثل ما يقولون، الحيلة في الاستحواذ على العميل
كيف أقدم أفضل سعر، وأقدم الوفرة أن يكون الفندق متاح
بأسرع وقت ممكن. اليوم أيش اللي يصير؟
خل أعطيك مثلًا موضوع
أيش اللي يفرق «المسافر» عن أي شركة أخرى موجودة؟
يوم بدأنا في التحول في 2017
قلنا احنا عندنا نموذج تقليدي للتعامل مع المسافرين
بس لازم نغيّر العملية وندرس اضطرابات العميل من الألف للياء
وعشان تقدم هذا الموضوع، عشان يعطيك النمو المطرد
أني كيف أقدر أكبّر الشغل بنفس الموارد الموجودة
نفترض عندي 2500 موظف، أبيع بـ 4 مليار
وبنفس الموظفين هذولي أبيع بـ 8 مليار
ما يحتاج أسوي استثمار زيادة إلا بشيء بسيط في التكلفة
و هذا، الحمد لله، اللي صار معنا اليوم في «المسافر»
بنينا ثقافة داخل الشركة أن احنا شركة تقنية
ما احنا بشركة سفر وسياحة
أنت تبغى تتوسع من خلال التقنية
ما تبغى تتوسع في أنك توظف ناس زيادة
توظف ناس زيادة، وللا روح تعاقد مع فندق واحد، ثاني، ثالث؛ لا
يوم سوينا هذا الموضوع في 2017
بنينا ثقافة أن احنا شركة تقنية
الحمد لله، نجحنا في جذب المواهب الموجودة على مستوى المنطقة
أنهم يجون يشتغلون عندنا، ويقول هذه شركة أقدر أطلّع مواهبي فيها
وهذا الموضوع مو سهل جدًّا
بعضهم يعتقد أنه جدًّا سهل
أنه خلاص جيب أنظمة وتعاقد مع شركة
الموضوع لا، فصار فيه استثمار كبير جدًّا عندنا
في الاستثمار في التقنية
مثلًا شفنا تجربة العميل وأذكر يوم بدينا
في مرحلة التحول للقنوات التفاعلية
كنا نجلس مع عملاء مثل جلستنا هذه
إذا جيت تسافر أيش تسوي؟ طيب كيف تبحث؟
والله أنا أبحث في منصة أجنبية وأبحث هنا وأبحث هنا وأشوف الفندق
طيب أيش يخليك تسوي كذا؟ عشان أشوف السعر
إذا حجزت مثلًا مرة مع الفندق، هل ترجع له مرة ثانية؟
وللا كل مرة تفحص وتتأكد من السعر؟
فدخلنا في تفصيل التفصيل عن تجربة العميل
بعدين قلنا هذه هي التجربة المثالية كمستخدم للتطبيق
اللي نبغاها تصير للعملاء
بعدين يوم سوينا هذا الشيء؛ بنى لنا القاعدة الأساسية
في موضوع البحث عن الفنادق
قلت لي هل هي عمولة وللا نضيف ربح؟
احنا كنا متعاقدين مع شركة، هي محرك البحث حقنا
أيش يسوي «المسافر» في موضوع الفنادق؟
هو يربط مع موردين لغرف في العالم
معليش خلنا نرجع خطوة وراء شوي
الآن الفنادق إذا جات بتوفر غرفها للمنصات
تتعامل مع موردين وللا تتعامل مع منصات؟
تتعامل مع منصات ومع موردين
الأصل إذا واحد توّه بيبدأ في السوق ذا، تروح مع المورد
تروح مع المورد لأنه عنده تنوّع كبير في الفنادق
هو اللي سوّى التفاوض معهم ورتب كل شيء
الفندق يجي يقول أنت يا مورد خذ الغرف هذه محجوزة لك
نعم
ما راح أوفرها للعملاء مباشرة، صح؟
على حسب الاتفاقية، أحيانًا لا
مثلًا لنفترض أن الفندق عنده 500 غرفة
يقول أنت دائمًا متاح لك كل يوم خمس غرف، كأنها مؤكدة لك
وخلاص بفكها أنا قبل 24 ساعة من كل يوم
فدائمًا تلاحظ لما تبحث في كثير من المنصات، يقول لك
باقي غرفتين، باقي غرفة، باقي غرفتين
هو قد يكون هذا هو مخزونه الموجود
ثم إذا خلّص يكلمهم ويقول يلا افتحوا لي غرف زيادة؛ فيفتحوا له زيادة
أو يكونون بالتزامن، يقولك كل الغرف متاحة
بس إذا انحجز شيء بقولك، خلاص راحت غرفة وللا راحت
100%
فأنا أسهل لي إذا بسوي خدمة لحجز فنادق؛ أني تعامل مع موردين
تتعامل مع موردين
من فيه أشهر الموردين؟
طبعًا فيه موردين «هوتيل بيدز» «إكسبيديا»
هذه من أكبر الشركات اللي تمتلك غرف على مستوى العالم
بالإضافة فيه موردين بأسواق معينة
مثلًا في تركيا في مورد معروف في السوق التركي
أيش اسمه؟
فيه شركات كثيرة حتى ما يحضرني الاسم
في أسبانيا موجود، وفي أوربا فيه شركات معروفة
أيش يسمون نوعية الشركات؟
«هوتيل بيدز» يسمونهم «بيذر» أو «روم بيذر»
الموردين هذولي؟
إيه، الصناعة حقتهم أني أملك أسرة
كم عدد المفاتيح اللي عندك؟ كم عدد كل شيء، فهو عند هذا الشيء
فنقدر لو ببحث اكتب مورد «هوتيل بيدز»
بالضبط، هذه إحدى الشركات الموجودة الكبيرة
ولكن «البيدز» موجودة، ودائمًا مصطلح الـ «بيدز» موجود عندهم
فالمورد يعطيك إياه بسعر التكلفة
يعطيك إياه على حسب الاتفاقية بينه وبين الفندق
طبعًا عنده وظيفة أساسية اسمها إدارة الدخل
هو يراقب العرض والطلب
إذا زاد الطلب؛ يرفع السعر
إذا قل العرض؛ ينقّص السعر
أحيانًا أقل من تكلفته بس ما تلقى غرفته فاضية
وطبعًا هذه يكون فيها ذكاء اصطناعي غالبًا في إدارة هذا الموضوع
وهذا اللي صاير معنا الآن
إيه، بس السعر اللي يعطيك إياه هو السعر التكلفة بالنسبة لك
سعر التكلفة بالنسبة لي و أنا أضيف عليه العمولة
وقتها أنا عندي مدير للدخل أو مدير للسعر هو اللي يراقب الأسعار
يقولك والله فيه طلب الآن في مكة في رمضان
لازم أرفع السعر
حتى لو تكلفتي 1000، ولكن السوق يستوعب أني أبيع بـ 1300
والعادة ما أربح 30% يحطها بـ 1300 لأن الطلب عالي جدًّا
وأنا، الحمد لله، وفقت أني عندي سعر كويس مع المورد
فهذا جزء، الجزء الثاني اللي، الحمد لله، يكون مرة كويس
إذا كان عندي نظام تقني جدًّا ممتاز
اللي هو أني أربط مباشرة مع الفندق
بس ليش مو بقروشة هذه تقعد تربط مع كل فندق؟
مثلًا شركة مثل «أكر» وهذه من أكبر الشركات على مستوى العالم
اللي تمتلك «فيرمونت» وتملك «روفلز» وتملك «سويس هوتل»
عندها أكثر من علامة تجارية
عندها مجموعة فنادق
مجموعة فنادق أنا أربط معهم
فوقتها إذا سوّى البحث عندي
فهو يشوف سعر المورد ويشوف سعر الفندق مباشرة
يشوف الأقل منهم، يطلعه للعميل
أنا يهمني أن العميل ياخذ أفضل سعر وأفضل اتفاق
عشان أحافظ عليهم
أنت تستمر بالربط مع المورد، لأن المورد ممكن يمر بفترة
يضطر أن ينزل السعر؛ عشان يقدر يصرّف الغرف
100% أنا قد ما أربط مع أكثر من شخص
قد ما أنه يكون فيه سعر متاح للعميل بشكل جدًّا ممتاز
وكلما قلّت العملية هذه؛ كلما قلت المخاطرة وكذلك قلّت الأرباح
ولكن كلما كثروا الموردين؛ أكيد بتزود أرباحي
والعميل حقي بيكون مبسوط، ولكن فيها مخاطرة
مثلًا أكّد مع واحد ثم بعدين تصير الغرفة راحت
من الموردين قصدك؟
نعم تصير الغرفة راحت، مثل ما أنت ذكر في مثال قبل شوي
أن يصير هو حاجزوا خمس غرف وللا عشر غرف
ثم بعدين يوم صار التأكيد، أكّد معي واحد من منصة ثانية عالمية
ثم راحت الغرفة
لأنه رابط مو بس معي أنا، مع أكثر من واحد
فوقتها أضطر أني أرتب الموضوع هذا
وأحاول أني أجد غرفة
تصير كثير من هذه الشغلة؟
تصير، أي نظام يصير فيه هذا الموضوع
وعشان كذا خل نكمل رحلة العميل
أيش اللي يخلي واحد يحجز مع «المسافر» وما يحجز مع غيره؟
عندنا فريق خدمة عملاء متاح 24 ساعة
أي تعديل، أي ترتيب، أي تعديل في الحجز
أو زيادة في الليالي، بلغي حجز
فيه عندنا فريق مختص، موجودين يحلّون هذا الموضوع
احنا بنرجع على خدمة العملاء، بس خلنا الحين على موضوع الفنادق
فقلنا أنتم عندكم ربط مع موردين
وربط مباشر مع مجموعة الفنادق الكبيرة
ما أتصور منطقي تروح لفندق موجود في مدينة وحدة
وتقول بربط معكم
100%
تروح غالبًا للكبار اللي عليهم طلب «فيرومونت» و«ماريوت»
بالضبط، بالإضافة أن محرك البحث أو أداة البحث اللي موجودة
محرك البحث
محرك الحجز
أو محرك الحجز، صحيح
محرك الحجز الموجود، أول كنا متعاقدين مع شركة تقدم الحل هذا
طبعًا على أي إجراء ياخذ له مبلغ
أي إجراء كحجز وللا؟
أي إجراء حجز ياخذ دولار، دولارين على حسب الاتفاقية
احنا قررنا قبل سنتين، احنا بنسوي المحرك البحث الخاص فينا
أول شيء، أضمن 100% إن شاء الله، أن ما في مشاكل مع الموردين
وإذا صار مشكلة أعرف المسبب من
هل هو المورد؟ وللا الشركة عندنا؟
عشان أعرف أتعامل معها في التعويض
الشيء الثاني، أوفر بشكل مرة كبير في الرسوم هذه
اللي ياخذونها مني قبل، أوفر فيها؛ فيكون فيها أرباح أكثر
محرك البحث هذا مثل مين؟ تقدر تضرب مثال؟
مالهم اسم، بس اليوم عندنا محرك بحث موجود
احنا أسسناه، واليوم بدأنا فيه
لا قصدي اللي متوفرين في السوق
فيه شركات كثيرة والله، في شركة اسمها «تي في»
فيه أكثر من شركة موجودة رابطين مع الناس
فأنتم سابقًا كان «المسافر» رابط بمحرك بحث
ومحرك البحث رابط مع موردين، والموردين رابط مع فنادق
صحيح
ففعليًّا كل واحد ياخذ له شوي، مبلغ له
بالضبط
وتصير صعب المنافسة، فتضطر أول شيء تشيل محرك البحث
بعدين تبدأ يمكن تشيل موردين، لأنك تربط مباشرة مع...
لا، طبعًا فيه نوعين من الخطوط
فيه الخطوط التجارية الأساسية
مثالنا الخطوط السعودية، الخطوط الإماراتية
هذه خطوط أساسية يتم ربطها من خلال «أماديوس» و «قاليليو»
فيه الخطوط اللي يسمونها الخطوط منخفضة التكلفة
الاقتصادية
الاقتصادية نعم
مثلًا طيران «ناس» يعتبر من هذه الخطوط
طيران «أديل» كذلك طيران «دبي» مثلًا
فهذه اللي يتم معهم الربط مباشرة، لأن لهم أنظمتهم الخاصة
مو رابطين مع «أماديوس»؟
مو برابطين مع «أماديوس» أو أي أنظمة من أنظمة الطيران
فنربط معهم مباشرة من غير أنظمتنا
بس ليش؟ أيش الفرق بينهم وبين الخطوط الرئيسية؟
في نظام الطيران، الخطوط الاقتصادية المنخفضة التكلفة
الهوامش حقتها مختلفة، فيبدوا لي أنهم لهم أنظمتهم الخاصة
بحيث أنهم قد ما يقدرون يحاولون ياخذون الفلوس
التحكم بالتكلفة، أن الأنظمة الكبرى هذه تأخذ إضافية
بالضبط، طبعًا فيه شركات كانت موجودة
اللي هي تصير الوسيط بين الشركات الاقتصادية
وشركات السفر والسياحة
كان فيه شركات تقنية، يقولك أنا أرتب الموضوع هذا
أربط معي أنا؛ أربطك بـ«ناس»
بالمحرك حق الفنادق
بالضبط، موجودة هذه. بس اليوم تطورت خطوط الطيران
على حسب تطور شركة السفر والسياحة
أنها تربط مباشرة مع خطوط الطيران المخفضة
وهذا مسوين احنا عندنا الآن
كان ودي أمر معك على...
الحين أتوقع واضح أيش الخدمات اللي تقدم للعميل بشكل عام
وكيف حتى ممكن لو واحد بيشتغل فيها
على الأقل بعض الفرص غطيناها
ودي أمر بشكل سريع على الشركات اللي عندكم
فيه شركة عندكم متخصصة في الحج والعمرة إذا ماني بغلطان
صحيح
أيش اسمها؟
شركة «مواسم»
أيش الفكرة حقتها؟
عندنا علاقات «مواسم» هي شركة حج وعمرة موجودة في مكة والمدينة
وعندنا فروع في أكثر من بلد في العالم
عندنا مكتب في إندونيسيا، موظفينا موجودين في إندونيسيا
عندنا مكتب في باكستان
عندنا برضه ممثلين لنا في أكثر من سوق
نحاول نخدم الجالية المسلمة في كل بلدان العالم
«مواسم» توفر خدمة السفر والسياحة
أو تجارب سفر للي يجون يعتمرون أو يحجون
من يوم استخراج فيزة العمرة أو فيزة الحج
وكذلك استقبالهم في المطار، سكنهم، تأدية الحج أو العمرة
ثم بعدين إذا عندهم أي وجهات إضافية
نقدر أن نرتب لهم هذا الشيء
فأنت برضه تاخذ فكرة خطة السفر للسياحة
ما أدري أيش يسمونها سياحة دينية وللا غيروها؟
سياحة دينية نعم
السياحة الدينية، هي اللي يسمونها «عمرة بلس» ؟
«عمرة بلس» هذه، اللهم لك الحمد، دائمًا الواحد يسأل عنها
يقول يا أخي السياحة صارت اليوم تتكلم
فعلًا، اليوم فيه مركز موجود للسعودية في العالم
قد يكون مو موجود في أي بلد موجود في العالم
أول شيء، الموقع الجغرافي
وجود الحرمين هذا بحد ذاته يعتبر شيء
أول شيء هو تكليف علينا
كيف نخدم الحجاج والمعتمرين وضيوف الرحمن
والحمد لله، اليوم من رأس الهرم
سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين وسمو ولي العهد
أنهم مهتمين بهذا الموضوع
فيه برنامج في الرؤية موجود، اسمه برنامج خدمة ضيوف الرحمن
وعندنا كذلك فيه كثير من الشركات، صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
تستهدف أنها تخدم ضيوف الرحمن بشكل مرة كبير
بالإضافة طبعًا التنوع الجغرافي، التنوع الثقافي، التنوع في الأجواء
يعطينا فرصة ممتازة أن قد ما نقدر نطوّل
من جلوس أي واحد يجي للسعودية
قد ما أن الدولة تستفيد، وكذلك يكون فيه تجربة ممتازة للزائر
هذه فكرة «عمرة بلس»؟
«عمرة بلس» وبعد ما تخلّص عمرة، زر أي مكان في السعودية
واكتشفنا أن كثير من الناس أكيد يجي لمكة والمدينة
أكيد بعضهم قد يؤدي فريضته
والناس اللي مؤدي فريضته؛ يجي يبغى يسوي سياحة
سياحة دينية وفعلًا سياحة روحية
احنا مثلًا فيه كثير من الناس كل رمضان يروح لمكة
أو يروح مرتين في مكة، قد يكون اعتمر ثلاثين مرة
الواجب الديني سوى اللي عليه
بس فيها سياحة، فيها سياحة دينية، فيها ترفيه عن النفس
فهذا الشيء يُخدم بتجارب كثيرة موجودة نقدر نسويها لهم
أذكر مرة كنت في زيارة لدبي، في شغل
وراجع بالطيارة من دبي، وراجع ليلة رأس السنة، يوم 29 ديسمبر
طبعًا طبيعة الناس يقولك أيش يطلعك من ...
خلاص اقعد في المكان اللي أنت فيه
أيش يطلعك من دبي ذاك الوقت!
اقعد ليلة رأس السنة واحتفالات
احتفالات
إيه، والرياض فيه احتفالات، بس دبي مشهورة بالاحتفالات
فركبت الطيارة، يوم دخلت لقيت عائلة
واحد يتكلم إنقليزي ولكن اللهجة حقه أمريكي
ولكن كأنه يعطي هندي شوي، ومعه زوجته أمريكية ومعاهم أطفالهم
وراكب، قلت غريبة أيش جايبهم ذول؟
بيطلعون من دبي بيرحون للرياض غريبة!
بس أنه ليلة رأس السنة، كان يشرب القهوة السعودية
وكان يعطيه أنواع تمر، فكان معجب بأنواع التمر
فأنا ودي...
استفزك من جميع النواحي كقصيمي
أيوة
جاي في ليلة رأس السنة، ويشرب قهوة وتمر
وليه؟ وشو له؟
فجيت قلت له، أنا ودي افتح موضوع بأي طريقة
يوم جاء موضوع التمور، قلت له على فكرة
ترى عندنا بالسعودية أكثر من 100 نوع تمر
قالوا إيه ممتاز، قلت معليش سؤال، وين رايح أنت؟
قال أنا رايح للرياض، ومن الرياض بروح «جيه إف كيه» بروح لنيويورك
قلت أيش جابك طيب؟
قال أنا لي أسبوعين، أنا مسلم وزوجتي مسلمة
جينا أخذنا عرض جيد من الخطوط السعودية
وجايين من نيويورك - جدة، خلصنا عمرتنا في مكة
قعدنا أسبوع في مكة، ثم يوم خلصنا من مكة، رحنا لدبي تمشينا
خلصنا من دبي، الحين راجعين للرياض
ومن الرياض على نيويورك مرة ثانية
فقلت له ما صار لك فرصة قعدت في جدة؟
قال لي قعدت ليلة في جدة بس
قال لي قعدت أشوف في الشاشة حق الطيارة، أشوف عندكم مشاريع
قال مرة ثانية لو فيه فعلًا خدمات
وفيه مكان يُزار، مو لازم نروح لدبي، بقعد في السعودية
طبعًا هذا الموضوع فعلًا، واليوم مع المشاريع الكبرى
اللي قاعدة تصير في السعودية
سواءً في المنطقة المركزية، عندك مثلًا وجهة «مسار»
هذه اللي تتطور في المنطقة المركزية في مكة
عندك مشروع البحر الأحمر، «العُلا»
«نيوم» إن شاء الله، مستقبلًا
«الدرعية» أُعلن عن مشاريع كثيرة
قمم «السودة» اللي أُعلن عنها قبل يومين
هذه بتخلي فيه مؤشر جدًّا مهم في موضوع السفر
حتى احنا في «المسافر» دائمًا نقيسه
اللي هو كم الوقت اللي قضاه العميل في السفر؟
هذا يؤثر على الناتج المحلي بكامله
إذا هو يصرف مثلًا 5000 في سفرته
إذا قعد يومين زيادة بيصرف 7000 ريال
فهذا يؤثر في الناتج المحلي بشكل مرة كبير
وتعرف اليوم في الناتج المحلي مشاركة القطاع السياحي
تقريبًا كانت 3% السنة هذه وصلنا 7%
ونطمح في 2030 نوصل 10%
فكلما قعدوا أكثر؛ كلما صرفوا أكثر وكلما استفاد الاقتصاد
كلما برضه هم شافوا السعودية وانبسطوا في تجربتهم
فهذا هو بالذات «عمرة بلس»
احنا مركزين اليوم في شركة «مواسم»
الحمد لله، نعمل مع وزارة الحج بشكل مرة كبير بالترويج لمكة والمدينة
وكل سوق يختلف عن سوق آخر، من ناحية البرامج الموجودة
أكيد سوق جاكرتا يختلف عن سوق باكستان
اليوم موظفينا في جاكرتا تعاطيهم الفنادق في مكة
والفنادق المطلوبة، غير موظفينا في باكستان
المعتمر والحاج الباكستاني له طلبات معينة
تختلف عن الإندونسيين
مثل أيش؟
مثلًا الأندونسيين يقول يا أخي أحب أني أخذ إقامة كاملة
اللي هو فطوري وغداي وعشاي يكون من ضمن سكني
الباكستاني لا ما يحب، يحب هو يدبر أموره
يقول لا تزود علي في السعر
قد ما تقدر تقلل السعر؛ أنا أكون مستفيد
كثير من الإندونسيين مثلًا يحب سواقين الباصات يكونون إندونسيين
عشان اللغة وكذا، يحبون هذا الشيء
كثير مثلًا من الناس يحبون يزورون بعض الأماكن
اللي لها بُعد تاريخي معين
مثلًا المساجد السبعة الموجودة في المدينة المنورة
يحبون يزورونها كثير من الجاليات المسلمة
بس مو كل الجاليات المسلمة يحبون يزورونها
فاحنا ندخل في التفاصيل عشان نعرف طبيعة كل سوق
في الحج والعمرة، ولا أقطع واردك
فيه فرص كبيرة لاستهداف الأجانب
وفي كل سوق بشكل مختلف
جدًّا، وهذا طبعًا...
مثل اللي سواه تقريبًا «فاروق» بس اللهم لأسواق ثانية
أنك تسوي محتوى محلي للراغبين في الحج والعمرة
أنا بفصّل لكم شيء على جوكم
سواءً في الأكل، سواءً في المعالم
سواءً في المجموعة اللي أحطكم معها
أو مثلًا خلنا نجيب طاري الأكل، لو أنا أسوي تقديم الطعام
لثلاث دول في شرق آسيا
اليوم، الحمد لله، يمكن شفنا إعلان اليوم أن الصين
تعرف السفر، طبعًا هذا مو بحج وعمرة، أتكلم عن سياحة
بس كمثال، أول سفر من المجموعات من الصين
تعرف الصينيين يسافرون 200 أو 300 واحد سوى
ولكن لا بد يكون فيه اتفاقية مع الدولة لاستقبال المجموعات
الحمد لله، اليوم السعودية أعلنت عنها
تم اعتماد السعودية كوجهة لسفر المجموعات من الصين
هذا للصين تحديدًا
للصين
هذا مجال للعمل التجاري بشكل مرة كبير
أول شيء إذا مثلًا دارس لغة صينية وللا أطقطق صيني
أقدر آخذ رخصة مرشد سياحي وأقدر اخدمهم
من وين من السعودية وللا من الصين؟
من السعودية آخذها من هيئة السياحة، إذا أنا أعرف صيني
إذا أنا متخصص في الأكل، أسوي لي خدمة أكل للصينيين
اللي هو البوكسات هذه حق الأكل
اللي تصير معهم في الباصات وللا إذا راحوا لأي مكان
أقدر أقدم طعام لهم
ففيه مجال للتطوير بشكل مرة كبير
عودًا على الحج والعمرة، يمكن أوضح نقطة كمشروع
احنا بسبب الاستثمار الكبير اللي سويناه في العمود الفقري حقنا
اللي هو وحدة سفر الأفراد، اللي هو «المسافر»
الحمد لله، من ناحية المنصات الرقمية والربط مع الموردين
وفهم طبيعة الأسواق
صار عندنا مجال لتطوير تجربة الحاج والمعتمر التقنية بشكل كبير
كنت تقريبًا قبل شهر كنت في جاكرتا
فيه فرصة كبيرة أني أربط مع كثير من شركات الحج والعمرة
يقول مابي أكلمك ولا تكلمني، اربطني مع النظام حقك
وأنا خلاص ادخل واحجز
فهذا الشيء لو أنا ما عندي الاستطاعة وعندي القدرة
أني جاهز تقنيًّا؛ كان ما أربط معه
وهذا اللي خلانا، الحمد لله، في آخر خمس سنوات
2015 كانت مبيعات «المسافر» تقريبًا حدود 100 مليون
2012 كانت 3 مليون، السنة هذه بنقفل 8 مليار
ما شاء الله
صح أن في مرحلة البداية إذا تكلمنا عن التسويق
أقول لك كيف وضعها
فأروح بداية أي زيادة في المبيعات؛ يقابلها زيادة في التكلفة
اليوم، الحمد لله، وصلنا مرحلة
إذا زادت المبيعات 30% قد أزود في التكلفة 5%
لأن سابقًا كان مكاتب
لا، حتى على وضع «المسافر» التقني
اليوم وصلنا مرحلة، عندنا القاعدة الأساسية جدًّا ممتازة
والحمد لله، أي مبلغ يزيد
وهذا قد يكون فيه أثر على المشروع، أخوي مشهور
أنا قد أسوي قاعدة أساسية لأي مشروع
في مرحلة التأسيس قد تطول أو تقصر
لازم أسوي استثمار كبير جدًّا أني أكبر القاعدة
بعدين أوصل لمرحلة معينة قد ما ينمو المشروع
خلاص يكون عندي أرباح ولا يحتاج أزود التكلفة
إيه، تزودها بشكل بسيط
بالضبط صدقت
عودة لنقطة الحج والعمرة، فيه ناس أتصور يتخيلون
لأنه شيء رئيسي عندنا في السعودية
ولأنه شيء مهم جدًّا، فمخدوم و ما عاد فيه فرص
فكل الناس، خلاص كل الشركات والحكومة قايمين بالواجب
طبعًا هم قايمين بالواجب للأشياء الأساسية
يمكن الكثير يعتقدون أن معاد فيه فرص لمشروع تجاري
بينما في الواقع ما زال فيه
فيه فرص كبيرة، واليوم وزارة الحج والعمرة
وفيه برنامج خدمة ضيوف الرحمن، كما قلت لك قبل شوي
وزارة الحج ممثلة بمعالي الوزير الدكتور «توفيق الربيعة» وفريقه
في تطوير في تجربة الحاج والمعتمر بشكل مرة كبير
سواءً من ناحية، اليوم المعتمرين يوصلون من 9 - 10 مليون في السنة
في 2030 يطمحون يوصلون 30 مليون
أوه ما شاء الله!
هذا مؤلم في الرؤية، وهذا موجود وفيه مجال كبير للتطوير
وشفت تجربة الحاج، نرجع للتجربة
فيها أكل، وفيها تنقل، وفيها بيروح وفيها بيلبس، وفيها مغسلة ملابس
وفيه أشياء كثيرة في المشروع
وما زالت مكة والمدينة، ما شاء الله، الله يشرفها والله يحفظها
فيها مجال كبير للتطور
واليوم فيه، الحمد لله، تطوير للبنية التحتية بشكل مرة كبير
واحنا شافين المشاريع اللي أعلنوا عنها في مكة والمدينة
الشيء الثاني، فيه تطوير للمنصات الرقمية
مثلًا، الحمد لله، احنا من الشركات اللي اخذنا رخصة
من الشركة للحجاج من السنة الماضية، اللي هو أفراد
أول أي واحد كان بيحج، لازم يقدم عن طريق السفارة السعودية
ولازم يعرف مطوّف، فيه شركات تسمى شركات «طوافة»
كانوا موجودين، ماسكين عمل الحجاج من عشرات السنين
اليوم هذولي موجودين، ولكن تم تنظيمهم، حولوهم شركات
واليوم في طور أن بعضهم قد يتحول إلى شركة مساهمة
بدأوا في الأسواق اللي فيها عدد المسلمين مو كبير جدًّا
مثلًا أسواق أوربا وأمريكا وأستراليا
هذولي، قال أي حاج فرد يدخل على منصة «نسك»
المملوكة لوزارة الحج، بالتزامن مع هيئة السياحة
يدخل على أكثر من حزمة للحجاج ويحجز حزمة ويجي
بدأوا فيها من السنة الماضية
احنا وحدة من ست شركات اخذنا الرخصة هذه، الحمد لله
وهذه ثقة كبيرة نعتز فيها
وفيها تكليف بشكل مرة كبير، كيف نقدم الخدمة
وفيها متطلبات أتصور عالية
فيها متطلبات، من ناحية أن يكون عندك الاستطاعة التقنية
عندك كذلك الملاءة المالية، فيه ضمانات معينة تقدم
ولكن أنا ما أشتغل لحالي، أنا فيه عندي موردين
أو مقاولين أشتغل معهم
فهي عبارة عن أنك ترتب السكن، بالإضافة لتجربة المشاعر
والإقامة في المشاعر في «منى» و«عرفة» و«مزدلفة»
التنقلات كذلك في فنادق مكة والمدينة
اليوم هذه أقدر أقول أنها في مرحلة بذرة صغيرة قاعدة تكبر
يطمحون ينقلون التجربة هذه، تجربة حج الأفراد إلى جميع أسواق العالم
فتكلمنا احنا عن شركة وحدة من الشركات
بالضبط
فيه شركة ثانية حق السياحة الداخلية
نعم صحيح
هذه أيش اسمها؟
شركة «اكتشف السعودية» اليوم هذه شعارها
هذه شعار الشركة؟
نعم، هذه شركة تملكها «المسافر»
أول ما أُعلن عن الفيزا السياحية في 2019؛ تم تدشين الشركة
والهدف إقامة تجارب سياحية داخل السعودية
ولكن فيها أكثر من مجال
المجال الأول، أني أكوّن شراكات مع كثير من مكاتب السفر والسياحة
الموجودين في السوق العالمي
مثلًا موقّع مع شركة موجودة في بريطانيا
فيجونا ناس يقولون بنسافر، مو بتطبيق
شركات السفر والسياحة موجودين
فهو يحاول يسوي تعزيز للسعودية
أو فيه ناس عندهم رغبة أنهم يجون لـ«العُلا»
أو يجون للرياض أو يجون لجدة
ويحضروا المباريات الحين
بالضبط، فهو يكون معزز لنا ويقدم أكثر من حزمة عن طريقنا
هو يسوّق لكم
يسوّق لنا. فاحنا نملك تجربة...
نحاول نرتب التجربة من يوم استقباله في المطار
نرسل له واحد يستقبله مع سيارة وسواق، مع مرشد سياحي
ونكوّن له تجربة مدة، عندنا طبعًا تنوّع في المنتجات هذه
اليوم هذا المشروع بدأ
الحمد لله، قاعدين نسوي...
مثلًا من فرنسا يجينا ناس، من إيطاليا، دول الخليج طبعًا بشكل مرة كبير
وعندنا شراكات كبيرة، والحمد لله، بسبب المقدرة التقنية
يمكن سبقنا كثير من الشركات الموجودة في السوق
هذا مجال في السياحة الوافدة أو السياحة الداخلية
المجال الآخر اللي هو يسمونه مجال الـ«مايس»
«مايس» اللي هي سياحة الاجتماعات والأحداث ورحلات المكافآت
اللي تسويها الشركات وكذلك المعارض
«مايس» أيش هي؟
«مايس» اللي هي اجتماعات، مكافآت، مؤتمرات، أحداث
هذه سياحة عمل بشكل عام
سياحة عمل، ولكن أيش يصير في الـ«مايس»؟
على سبيل المثال، «فورميلا 1» صار في السعودية
فيه كثير من الناس اللي يجون منظمين
ويحتاجون فنادق ويحتاجون تنقل
منظمين من «فورميلا 1» أو من الفِرق
أنا أقدم لهم الحلول هذه، فقاعد أحاول أرتب مع الجهات الحكومية
أرتب مع الجهات الخاصة، أرتب مع «فورميلا 1» أن أي فريق بيجي
أنا أمسك الفريق كامل، أرتب له رحلته
الترتيبات هذه تكون مع الجهة الحكومية وللا مع الفريق مباشرة؟
كلهم، فيه شركات حكومية، مثلًا «ليب» صار
نظمته وزارة الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات
فيه كثير من الناس اللي تكلموا أو قدموا محاضرات
أو كذلك روجوا لكثير من الشركات؛ جاوا
قد يكونون عشر أشخاص وللا مئة شخص
هذا مشروع مره ممتاز، يقول أنا أمسكه
ويُعلن عنها في منصة «اعتماد» المشاريع هذه
فممكن حتى الشركات الصغيرة تساهم
تقدر تساهم أو كذلك الشركات الصغيرة توقّع مع الشركات الكبيرة
يجي يوقّع مع «المسافر» يقول يا أخي أنا عندي سيارات
وللا عندي منظمين أو منسقين موجدين في الحدث نفسه
أنا أقدر أرتب معك
فخلاص إذا جاني حدث معين؛ على طول أرتب معه
لأنك ما تقدر تسوّي كل شيء بنفسك، مستحيل
بالضبط، وهذا اللي صاير اليوم فيه كثير من منظومات
هذه سياحة. مثلًا واحدة من الأشياء اللي نفتخر فيها
صراحة سويناها كحدث «مايس»
مثلًا تذكر كأس السعودية حق الفروسية
كأس السعودية، واحد من أعلى الفعاليات اللي تصير في السعودية
وصراحة لها عمق تاريخي، عمق ثقافي
ومربوط بالمملكة العربية السعودية
احنا في السنة الماضية واللي قبلها
كنا من الشركات اللي ساهمنا في حجوزات
جميع اللي جايين بخيولهم من خارج السعودية
من اليابان، من أوربا، من أمريكا
حتى نقل خيولهم، استقبالهم
شلون نسفّر الخيول؟
أكثرها يمكن، كل شيء له...
مثل الطائرات الخاصة، فيه طائرات خاصة للخيول
اسطبل طائر وللا شلون
فيه حلول كثيرة جدًّا
بالإضافة سوينا لهم رحلة داخل الرياض
بس جد ودي أعرف شلون يطير الخيل؟
من خلال شركات شحن وموجودة تشحن هذا الشيء ومخصصة له
ومجهزة
إيه، أو يدخل كذا مثل القفص يدخل داخل الطيارة
بشوفه في اليوتيوب بعد الحلقة، إن شاء الله
صار لنا تجربة جدًّا ممتازة
وكثير من الفعاليات تصير في السعودية مستمرة
مؤتمر مستقبل الاستثمار الـ«إف آي آي»
شاركنا في استقبال الكثير من الوفود
فيه كثير من فعالياتته صارت موجودة؛ سويناها
كذلك من التجارب اللي جدًّا ممتازة، وتعلمنا منها بشكل كبير
صار فيها صعوبات وتحديات مرة كبيرة
تجربة شتاء «طنطورة» في 2019
شتاء «طنطورة» اشتغلت شركة «المسافر» مع «اكتشف السعودية»
مع الهيئة الملكية لـ«العُلا»
لتصميم منتجات للقادمين لـ«العُلا»
وكانت تجربة فريدة، ما قد صارت قبل
أن شركة تمسك الحدث مدة ثلاثة شهور
تقريبًا كان فيه أكثر من 250 موظف موجودين في «العُلا»
كلهم من شباب وبنات «العٌلا»وكذلك كلهم شباب وبنات سعوديين
تم تدريبهم، تم تصميم المنتجات
كانت بالتزامن مع الهيئة الملكية لـ«العٌلا»
تعلمنا منها بشكل مرة كبير
ومنها انطلقنا للكثير من الفعاليات الموجودة
من الشيء اللي قاعدين نسويه الآن مع كروز السعودية
أول ما تم تدشين الكروز
أيش هو كروز السعودية؟
كروز السعودية هذه شركة تتبع لصندوق الاستثمارات العامة
سفينة كبيرة
هو الكروز اللي يطلعوا عليه مشاهير؟
أذكر شفت سناب فيه مشاهير صوروا في كروز طالعين
في السعودية نعم، يمكن يطلع فيها مشاهير
احنا من الشركات اللي وقعنا شراكة معهم
وسوينا تسويق لمنتجاتهم في 2021
فيه أكثر من مرة أخذنا الكروز بالكامل
للكثير من الشركات الكبيرة في السعودية
فيه شركات كانت بتطلع عملاءها أو بنوك
أو بتسوي اجتماع للمستثمرين
تخيل أخذنا السفينة كاملة
شلون توصل للناس هذولي؟
أنت قلت لي مثلًا، جهات حكومية يطرحونها في منصة «اعتماد»
طبعًا مو بالضرورة، فيه أشياء خارج منصة «اعتماد»
يكونوا بالتواصل المباشر ويخلونها، أيش رأيكم نشتغل كعرض عليكم
قبل ما يكون فيه منصة مطروحة
100%
الشركات شلون ترتبونها معهم؟
الشركات أكيد هم ما وثقوا فينا إلا أنهم جربونا مرة ومرتين وثلاثة وأربعة
يمكن جربنا مع ناس؛ خسرناهم
ما قدمنا لهم تجربة ممتازة
بس أعتقد هذا بيكون على حسب حجم الشركة
أنت كشركتك، كيف تقدر تقدم الخدمة
أنت ذكرت مثال قبل شوي، عن واحد اللي هو حق السيارات
فيه كثير من الناس عنده أسطول سيارات
يمكن عشرين أو ثلاثين سيارة، ترى ما هو بشيء مرة كبير
يرتب مع أكثر من الشركة، يقول إذا عندكم وفود
وتحتاجون سيارات مع سواقين؛ ترانا نقدم لكم
يجربونا مرتين، ثلاثة، وبعدين خلاص يقولون ما يبغون إلا هم
أتوقع أن بناء رضا العميل يتم بالتجربة مرة أو مرتين
اللي أعرفه، هذا بدأ الظاهر ثلاث سيارات أو بسيارتين، حتى مو...
ما شاء الله، واليوم كم أسطوله؟
ما شاء الله، اليوم دعس
ما أذكر التفاصيل كلها، لكنه رجال...
علمنا من هو عشان نتعاقد معه، إن شاء الله
افتح شركة ونتعاقد معاك
لا أخوي مرتاح
يمكن يكون مدخل ممتاز على موضوع استهداف العملاء
سواءً محليًّا أو عالميًّا
طريقة الاستهداف أنت ذكرت مثال
أنك تتعاقد مع شركات السياحة والسفر اللي برّا
أن يا جماعة تبون... تروح عند فرنسا، تقول
قول لهم اللي بيشوف «بنزيما» في السعودية
ترى عندنا أكثر من حزمة، تعالوا
صحيح 100%
فروّجوا لنا
وبدت تجي لنا طلبات على فكرة
كيف؟
كأس العالم للأندية بيصير في جدة في آخر السنة
فتجينا من الآن طلبات
هذه الفكرة أنك تتعامل مع شركات السياحة والسفر اللي برّا
صحيح
تقول أنا أضبطكم؛ بيعوا لي
هل تستهدفون الناس بشكل مباشر، الأفراد اللي برا وللا؟
حاليًّا، لا في هذا الأسواق
احنا مؤمنين أن لو بتدخل في تجربة العميل بتفاصيلها؛ بتبعد عن التركيز
اليوم لا، قاعدين نستهدف في الأسواق الخارجية
نتعامل مع شركات خارجية
ومحليًّا شلون تستهدف العميل؟
حاليًّا عاد تجربة «المسافر» تجربة ثرية في التسويق
اللي هي سفر أفراد
بدأنا أول ما صار الاستحواذ على «المسافر»
بشكل كامل من قبل المجموعة
الحمد لله، كان فيه وحدة من التحديات
كيف تقنع المستثمرين أو مجلس الإدارة أنك تستثمر في التسويق
أحتاج مبلغ مرة كبير، عشان أبدأ في مرحلة الوعي
أني أعرف الناس أيش هي «المسافر»
فبدأنا بشيء ممتاز جدًّا، واللي هو موضوع رعاية الأندية
بديتوا مع «الأهلي» الظاهر
بدينا مع «الأهلي» «التعاون»
صار لنا تجربة بعد في أكثر من مجال
في الملاعب كان «المسافر» منتشر
فاليوم عرفت الناس بعد سنتين
أن فيه شركة حق سفر وسياحة اسمها «المسافر»
وعندهم تطبيق وعندهم موقع إلكتروني
بعدين دخلنا في مرحلة، أن الناس عرفونا، كيف أحولهم لعملاء لي؟
فدخلنا في موضوع التسويق الرقمي
طبعًا التسويق الرقمي عالم مرة كبير
اللي هو موضوع إذا بحثت في قوقل يطلع لك «المسافر» أول واحد
كتبت لندن يطلع لك مبلغ على «المسافر»
سواءً في منصات كبيرة مثل قوقل، يوتيوب
أتوقع على وجهات أو حتى على اسمكم
وجهات أو اسمكم، وجهات فيه لها حيل مرة كثيرة
أحط الكلمات، وأحط كذا
حتى موضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم قد تتكلم
ويطلع لك إعلان «المسافر» موجود في يوتيوب
وللا في أي منصة موجودة يحبونها الناس
اليوم احنا فعالين جدًّا في سناب شات، يوتيوب، وكذلك في تيك توك الآن
بس الاستهداف هل يكون مثلًا بشكل رئيسي على السعر؟
وللا يكون على شمولية الخدمة
وللا أيش الشيء اللي تقدر تقول بستهدف الناس فيه؟
احنا نركز على القيمة أول شيء
أن أنا اشريت من «المسافر» أيش أستفيد؟
فعلًا البداية عشان أستهدف الكبير كان موضوع السعر
فكنا نسوي استثمار كبير في موضوع خصومات الأسعار
وقد نخسر في بعض الأحيان، بسبب أني أحاول أجيب عميل جديد
وفعلًا كوّنا قاعدة عملاء مرة كبيرة
اليوم، الحمد لله، تقريبًا قد أصل إلى 100 مليون عملية عبر الإنترنت
100 مليون عملية؟
100 مليون في السنة، أحيانًا أوصل إلى 120 مليون
عندي أكثر من 3.5 مليون عميل فعّال في المنصة
الفعالية تقيسونها كم؟
الفعالية 3.5 مليون، يعني يدخل ويسوي بحث
أيش هو العميل الفعال؟ أيش تعريفه؟
تعريفه أنه يدخل ويسوي بحث
أنه يبحث عن وجهة
يبحث وكل شيء
بالإضافة عندي تقريبًا حدود 800 ألف عميل
يسوي حجز معنا وكل شيء
بس فيه عميل يبحث، ويدخل مرة ثانية وكل شيء
طبعًا تعرف التتبع لنا من خلال الإيميل
ومن خلال عنوان «الآي بي» نقدر نعرف كم عندنا عميل
فالعميل الفعال هو العميل اللي يبحث مرة في شهر؟
بالضبط، دائمًا يبحث في «المسافر»
والـ 800 ألف هذولي؟
اللي سووا حجز معي
أيش تسمونهم؟
عميل
هذا عميل، نعم بالضبط
طبعًا هذا تم، بس في معلومة بعد بقولك إياها
كثير من الناس، يمكن  تذكر موضوع ارفع الشاشة
وللا واحد من المشاهير يصور ويقول
والله أنا مسافر عند طريق «المسافر»
واليوم فيه كود خصم، هذا كود الخصم دخلوه
وهذا كان انشهر فيها «المسافر»
أذكر في وقت من الأوقات، بعد مرحلة رعاية الأندية وكل شيء
دخلنا كثير مع المؤثرين، كانت في فترة من الفترات
فيها عنصر جذب جدًّا ممتاز، بالإضافة للتسويق الرقمي
في فترة من الفترات، كنا متعاقدين مع أكثر من ستين مؤثر في وقت واحد
أن يسوّق لهذا الموضوع
كان الهدف أني أبني قاعدة كبيرة من العملاء
وأحاول أكبّر الحصة السوقية حقتي قد ما أقدر
مو الجديد التعاون مع المؤثرين كمبيعات؟
في ذاك الوقت كان فعلًا مؤثر
كيف نقدر نقيسها؟
لأن إذا دخّل الكود الشخص
نقدر نعرف أن هذه العملية تمت من خلال الكود
ولكن اليوم، الحمد لله، وصلنا لمستوى جدًّا صحي
80% أو 81% من مبيعاتنا من خلال قنوات غير مدفوعة
لا هي من خلال قوقل، ولا هي من خلال سناب شات
بس عرفوكم الناس فيجوكم مباشرة
ممتاز، فهذا معناته أن العميل مبسوط مني، راضي
بس سؤال على المؤثرين، من تجربتكم
الأفضل اللي مختصين في السياحة والسفر؟
وللا ما يفرق كل العالم يبون يسافرون؟
أعتقد نعم، أعتقد موضوع السفر يختلف
وبعدين اليوم لو نشوف مثلًا عندنا السفر، أخوي مشهور
عندنا تقريبًا 35% من السفر
اللي يتم عن طريق «المسافر» داخل السعودية
و 15% أو 12% في دول الخليج، و 50% دول العالم كاملةً
فهذه تعطيني أن فيه ناس قد يستخدموا «المسافر»
بيزور أمه، بيزور أبوه، بيزور أقاربه، عنده رحلة عمل
بيروح لمكة، بيروح يعتمر
فأعتقد ما نستهدف الناس اللي خاصين بالسفر؛ لا
نستهدف أي شخص
على حسب طبعًا تواجده في أي مدينة
مثلًا نبغى أهل جدة يستخدمون «المسافر» بشكل أكبر
فنحاول نشوف أحد المؤثرين مقيم في جدة
ومتابعينه أكثرهم من جدة
فيه لنا تجربة مرة ممتازة في موضوع التسويق في سوق الكويت
احنا بدينا في السعودية، كان قوتنا في الرياض
في شمال المملكة وجنوب المملكة والغرب
كان «المسافر» مو مرة مشهور
سوّينا شراكة مع بنك «الراجحي»
هذا الكلام 2018
صار أغلب مستخدمينا في الرياض وفي القصيم
وكان وقتها مصرف «الراجحي» مركز على المنطقتين هذه
واليوم عندنا علاقة استراتيجية وشراكة استراتيجية
مع المصرف بشكل مرة كبير
بعدين مع تطور الشراكة هذه
اليوم «المسافر» موجود في أكثر مناطق المملكة
كيف انتقلنا للكويت؟
شفنا فيه كثير من الحجوزات، بحكم أن المشاهير اللي كانوا يعلنون
كثير من الحجوزات
صار يجينا طلبات من الكويت، ويحجزون بالريال السعودي
فقلنا كيف نقدر ندخل سوق الكويت؟
شفنا وقلنا لازم ندرس المسافر الكويتي
أو المستهلك الكويتي كيف يسافر
فشفنا أنهم قريبين جدًّا من السعوديين
بل أن فيه عندهم سفر أكثر من السعوديين
بحكم أن اليوم السعودية فيها سفر
ولكن يقدر واحد يسافر من الرياض إلى جدة ينبسط
ويسافر من الرياض للجنوب، قد يروح خط بالسيارة، يزور أقاربه
في الكويت لا، يا يسافر برّا الكويت، يا يقعد جوّا الكويت
فكنّا جريئين، دخلنا سوق الكويت
بدأنا في منصة الأونلاين
صار الواحد إذا دخل في الكويت، المنصة تكون مختلفة
مثلًا اليوم في السعودية، موجود عندك الطيران والفنادق والشالهيات
موجودة كأيقونات
لما تدخل من الكويت لا، فيه الطيران والفنادق فقط
وموجود الدينار الكويتي
بدأنا في الأونلاين، وسوينا حملة دعائية مرة ممتازة
إذا تعرف الكويت في شارع الخليج سوّينا إعلانات في الخارج
كان «المسافر» تشوفه في كل مكان
وكان فيها جراءة في الطريقة
وهذه أقول لك إياها، الحمد لله، توفقنا
بقيادة تنفيذية ومجلس إدارة، عنده إيمان كامل بالعلامة التجارية
فكان فيه ضخ فلوس مرة كويس
بالإضافة سوينا إعلانات من ممثلين وممثلات كوتيين
باللهجة الكويتية عن «المسافر»
إعلان خاص بالسوق الكويتي ويطلع لك
إذا دخلت في السناب شات تفتح
يطلع لك الإعلان الكويتي إذا أنت في السعودية
استهدفت السياحة في السعودية
مالك لوا، يستهدف المستهلك الكويتي اللي يسافر للعالم
بغض النظر على السعودية وللا لا
إيه بالضبط
أنا أشوفهم برضه يجون كثير للسعودية
يجون فعلًا أكثر جنسية، أكثر سياح، فعلًا صحيح
أتكلم عن هذا في 2019
يوم قعدنا تسعة شهور، ما شاء الله، المبيعات بدأت ترتفع
أمورنا تمام، انعرفنا في السوق
قلنا لازم، وهذ سؤال يمكن سألتني إياه أنت قبل
ولكن لعلي الحين فرصة أني أجاوب عليه
في موضوع سفر الأفراد والتسويق
قلنا لازم نفتح فرع
وتذكرت قصة، أنا بديت في المجموعة في 2019 أولها
فكان المطلوب مني أن نحاول نرتب الفروع
فكان يجي واحد في بالي، يا أخي أنا صراحة أونلاين ليش أفتح فرع؟
توني بسألك عليه
أيش يخليني أفتح فرع؟
وإلى الحين عندكم فروع
إلى الآن عندنا فروع والفروع تشتغل
وفيه عليها طلبات وكل شيء
ولكن لا تنسى موضوع القنوات التفاعلية
إيه، بس أنا أبغى شيء، حتى لو ما بستخدم التطبيق بدق عليك
ليش أروح الفرع؟
فيه واحد يجي هو وزوجته، فيه واحد يجي هو عياله
فيه قد يكون إذا عندك وجهات متعددة
نفترض مثلًا بتروح الرياض - القاهرة، القاهرة - الساحل الشمالي
الساحل الشمالي - شرم الشيخ، ثم بترجع
تحتاج فنادق في كل الأماكن، وقد تحتاج سيارة وسواق
وقد تحتاج فيزا لخدامتك إذا بتسافر معك
هذا كله يسوي لك إياه مستشار السفر، اللي موجود في الفرع
صعبة أنك تسويها من خلال التطبيق أو تكلم
بتكلم وكل شيء، بس لما تجلس قدام شخص؛ الموثوق جدًّا عالية
ولا هو بكل الناس عندهم الثقافة في السفر والمعرفة بنفس المستوى
فيه ناس يحب يتكلم مع شخص
والخدمة هذه أتصور أنك تشوف قيمة كل الأشياء اللي تقدمها
وتضيف عليها نسبة زيادة، مقابل خدمة مستشار السفر، لأنها تكلفة
شيء بسيط جدًّا، اللي فرق بين أنك تحجز في التطبيق
كم يعني؟
تتكلم عن عشرات الريالات، ماهو بشيء عالي جدًّا
معقولة؟
إيه نعم، بس بقولك هذه أيش هدفها؟
اليوم قوة العلامة التجارية كعلامة تجارية إذا هي موجودة أونلاين
بس لما أشوفها، لما أدخل في الكويت مثلًا
فتحنا في المركز التجاري «أفينيوس»
اللي هو أكبر معلم معروف موجود في الكويت
موجود فيه فرع «المسافر»
موجود فيه موظفيننا هناك، وزملاءنا وزميلاتنا موجودين
هذا يعطيني قوة كعلامة تجارية، أني موجود أونلاين
وموجود مركز اتصال، وموجود كذلك في فرع
فكثير من اللي يجونا حاجز في الأونلاين، فيمر على الفرع
وهو مار هناك، يقول بعد إذنكم أنا حجزت هنا، بس ودي أعدّل
فيكون مركز لخدمة العملاء، ويعطيه موثوقية جدًّا للعلامة تجارية
وهذه صارت، الحمد لله
تجربة المجموعة سابقًا، يوم كانت «الطيار»
كان عندنا فروع كثيرة لـ«الطيار» سوينا لبعضها ترتيب
وقفلنا كثير من الفروع اللي غير مجدية
مثل ما قلت هل هي تشتغل وللا لا
ولكن اكتشفنا أن السوق مرة كبير
ويستوعب أن يكون فيه قناة إضافية اللي هي...
طيب هذه تجربة الفروع، أنا مستحيل أن أروح الفرع
بس خلنا نقول تضيف مصداقية، تروّج للعلامة التجارية
مركز الاتصال مثلًا، هل فيه ناس كثير اللي اليوم يستخدمونه؟
إيه، كثير مبيعات
مبيعات من خلال مركز الاتصال؟
نعم. السلام عليكم هلا والله، أنا أبي أحجز المنطقة الفلانية
كم السعر؟ كذا، وهو جالس معاه على الخط
يجي له رابط دفع، يدفع؛ تجيه على طول التذكرة على الإيميل
بس كم يشكلون نسبة هذولي؟
يشكلون الآن تقريبًا حدود 14% أو 12%
ما زال عدد قليل، بس أحس أسهل أونلاين
بس فيه قناة ثانية، اللي قاعدة تنمو بشكل مرة كبير
اللي هي الواتساب
استثمرنا فيها بشكل مرة كبير، أن يكون فيه روبوت
اللي هو الذكاء الاصطناعي فيها
فترسل رسالة، يرد عليك واحد، وين وجهتك؟
تقول مثلًا وجهتي لندن، يقول لك حط التاريخ
هذا كله روبوت من خلال الذكاء الاصطناعي
لما توصل للمرحلة الأخيرة يعطيك الخيارات
خلاص يشبك معك موظف أو موظفة موجودين
يخلص لك اجراءاتك كاملة وتكمل حجزك خلال الواتساب
اليوم الواتساب يشكل 15% من مبيعاتنا، بشكل مرة كبير
تعرف اليوم فيه شركات تدار من خلال الواتساب
اليوم صار الواتساب وسيلة فعالة كثير للتخاطب
ونقطة أنها تبيع ممتازة على كذا
نعم ممتازة جدًّا
وفيها اختصار الوقت، وفيها برضه تقدر تقيس
سلوك العميل بشكل مرة سهل
متى أرسلك؟ متى قرر؟ فتقدر تعرف تجربته
شخصيًّا أحس أنها بطيئة صراحة
أنت ما جربت «المسافر» إذا جربت
لا، مو بطيئة عندكم، بطيئة بشكل عام كفكرة
أني أروح أقول لشات بوت في الواتساب
أبي أسافرـ متى تبي تسافر؟
أبي أسافر كذا
هذه ثواني
افتح التطبيق وأحط تواريخ
لا، فيه ناس بيسألوا. يقول أيش رأيك عطني خيارات متاحة للفنادق
يقول والله كذا
يسأل يقول طيب شوف لي شيء في منطقة، مثلًا
في القاهرة أبغى شيء على «النيل»
لا، أبغى شيء في المناطق الجديدة في القاهرة
في المقابل، هنا دخلنا في موضوع
أعتقد أننا من الشركات التي استحدثت
وظيفة جديدة في سوق السفر والسياحة
اللي اسمها مستشار سفر
أول شركات السفر والسياحة تدخل على الموظف
فيه موظف تذاكر، إذا حجزت تذكرتك، تقول وين الفنادق؟
يقول روح فيه موظف اسمه موظفين سياحة، منفصلين عن بعض
في 2019 يوم بدأنا في موضوع التحول
كانت تجربة صراحة نفخر فيها كلنا
سوينا النظام، تجربة العميل
جلسنا مع الناس وفهمنا منهم
سوينا نظام مرة ممتاز، فتحنا فروع جدًّا ممتازة
سوينا مركز اتصال ممتاز، الواتساب ممتاز
فقلنا بس الأنظمة هذه والمنتجات ممتازة
ولكن إذا ما كان فيه رأس مال بشري أو أفراد
أو ناس يقدمون الخدمة صح؛ أعتقد أننا بنفشل
فقررنا نسوي أكاديمية، سميناها أكاديمية «المسافر»
وسويناها في الرياض
كان الهدف أن يكون عندنا شباب وبنات سعوديين
من كل مناطق المملكة كمستشارين سفر
أول كان نظام، موظفين خاصين بالتذاكر، وموظفين خاصين بالفنادق
مستشار السفر يعطيك التجربة كاملة من الألف إلى الياء
ومدرَب على هذا الشيء
فتحتنا الأكاديمية، صممناها بتصميم جدًّا ممتاز
وقتها تخاطبنا وقتها مع وزارة الموارد البشرية
أن نبغى مباركة المشروع، فعلًا وقتها
أذكر وكيل وزارة لشؤون التوطين وقتها حضر معنا التخرج
بس شلون تدربون الناس؟
استقطبنا ثمانين واحد ووحدة من تبوك الين نجران
تبوك أذكر فيه فيه عندنا موظفين، موظف وموظفة
«العُلا» موظف وموظفة، القصيم يمكن حدود أربعة موظفين
الرياض، جمعناهم ندربهم على المهارات الأساسية
الإقناع، الاستماع، كيف أنك تقنع العميل، كيف أنك تفهم منه
كيف تتكلم معاه، سواءً من خلال الواتساب، من خلال الاتصال
أو من خلال المخاطبة أو المواجهة
استحدثنا شيء اسمه المفاهيم الأساسية لخدمة العميل
إذا دخل العميل عندك في الفرع مثلًا
لازم تقوم له، لازم تفتح للباب، لازم تضيفه
واليوم تدخل فروعنا حق «المسافر» تجربة جدًّا مختلفة
عن أي مكتب سفر وسياحة آخر
لا من ناحية الديكور، لا من ناحية الشاشات الموجودة
لا من ناحية الإعلانات، لا من ناحية نوعية شبابنا وبناتنا
الموجودين في الفروع
كذلك فيه مركز الاتصال
انتقلنا كذلك بعدين لتدريبهم على النظام
فجبنا «أمديوس» وجبنا «قاليليو» هم اللي يدربونهم
والأعمق من كذا، شفنا أكثر خمسة عشر وجهة سياحية
يحبون يسافرون لها السعوديين، منها السعودية
دربنا موظفينا وموظفاتنا على الوجهات هذه
جدة أيش فيها؟ أيش فيها أشياء أساسية؟
فيها نافورة «الحمراء» اللي هي النافورة العالية
فيها الممشى، فيها البلد
نفس الفكرة في «العُلا» فيه منطقة «الحِجر»
فيه صخرة الفيل، وفيه كذا
وندخل لهم بالتفصيل، أيش البعد التاريخي حقها وكل شيء
هذا في مستوى السعودية
جينا وقلنا بريطانيا، الناس تروح إلى لندن
بس فيه وجهات أخرى في بريطانيا
عندنا شراكات مع هيئات كثيرة للسياحة في العالم
جاوا هم ودربوا الناس
هيئة سياحة بريطانيا جات دربت موظفينا
هيئة سياحة المالديف، هيئة سياحة البحرين
يدربونهم على أيش؟ يقولون ترى في البحرين
بتروح إلى المنطقة الفلانية، هي في منطقة المطاعم
فيها المكان الفلاني، المطاعم الموجودة كذا
أيش الاستفادة منهم؟
من هم؟
الهيئات هذه
هذا موضوع آخر له علاقة بالتسويق بنتكلم عنها
وهذا جزء من النجاحات، الحمد لله، اللي نفتخر فيها
دربوهم، لا وشرطنا عليهم، تدربونهم
بس لازم بعضهم تستضيفونهم
فالثمانين واحد، كل ثمانية سافروا لوجهة
على أيام حتى العلاقات أذكر كان وقتها
بيروت كانت متاحة وما كان فيها مشاكل
واللي راح إلى بيروت، واللي راح إلى المالديف
واللي راح إلى جورجيا واللي راح لتركيا
الله انبسطوا المجموعة ذي
إيه راحوا بهدف، تخيل يروحون خمسة أيام، كل يومين في ديرة
مثلًا يروحون إسطنبول ومن اسطنبول يروحون «بودروم»
ومن «بودروم» يروحون مثلًا
بس ما تحس الحين ذولي إذا رجعوا بتصير نفس المشكلة
حق تنقلهم من موظف لموظف؟
أنا بحجز لندن، دقيقة بحولك على...
لا مالك لوا، أيش سوينا؟
أذكر طلبنا منهم وقتها أن يسوون عرض عن اللي سووه
وفيديو ويصورون، فجاوا مستمتعين فيه
وسوينا مكتبة للتدريب
اليوم عندنا مدير عام التدريب
وعندنا وحدة كاملة للتطوير والتدريب على مستوى الشركة
سواءً تدريب الأنظمة، الأشياء الجديدة
عندنا تعاقد مو فقط على مستوى مستشارين السفر
حتى على مستوى القيادات
عندنا تعاقد مع «كلية هارفرد للأعمال» مع «كورسيرا»
مع الأشياء العلاقة بالمهارات الناعمة
كلها مع منصات عالمية تسوي تدريب أونلاين
إيه، لأنك أنت بتبدل الجهد بذولي
ما تبي ترجع تعيده نفسه مع ناس ثانيين
100% فسوينا المنصة هذه للتدريب
اليوم بشكل أسبوعي فيه دورات تدريبية للموظفين
نجي الآن على موضوع الشراكات مع هيئات السياحة
تقول أيش يستفيدون؟
لأني أعرف فيه جهات أو شركات كثير
استفادوا في التعاون مع هيئات السياحة في دول مختلفة
100%
بس ما أعرف تفاصيلها صراحة
الطريقة طبعًا لعلي أذكر تجربتنا مع تايلند
أول ما تم السماح للسفر إلى تايلند في سنة 2022
تم التخاطب مع هيئة سياحة تايلند وتخاطبوا معنا
قالوا نبغى نسوي معكم حملة للتعريف بتايلند
أيش معنى التعريف تايلند؟
الحمد لله، عندنا المتابعين في منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
تقريبًا حدود مليون متابع
فجينا نسوي برامج عن تايلند، نسوي مسابقات عن تايلند
أيش أشهر مدينة في تايلند؟
نحط صورة  موجودة مثلًا في «بانكوك»
نقول اللي يجاوب عليها ويعرف وين الصورة هذه
له تذكرة مجانًا وإلا حجز ليلتين مجانًا في الجهة اللي بيعرفها
سوينا هذه المسابقة، بالإضافة سوينا حملات دعائية عن هذه الوجهة
وتكون مدعومة من هيئة السياحة
يدفعون من عندهم مبلغ واحنا من عندنا مبلغ
نقول اللي يحجز لتايلند مثلًا له خصم كذا
وهو يصير مدعوم من نفس هيئة سياحة تايلند
هيئات السياحة بشكل عام، عندهم ميزانيات لدعم السياحة
للتسويق، وهذا اللي صار مع هيئة سياحة السعودية
هيئة سياحة السعودية اليوم عندها علاقة مع كثير
احنا عندنا شراكة معهم للتسويق
مثلًا لموسم الصيف تعاقدوا مع «المسافر» لعمل أكثر من حزمة
أو منتجات للتسويق للسياحة في السعودية
وسويناها، والحمد لله، أثبتت نجاحها
اليوم مع موسم الرياض، قاعدين نشغلين على أشياء من هذا النوع
وكذلك هيئة السياحة مع شركات عالمية
احنا، الحمد لله، من خلال شركة «اكتشف السعودية»
نروح معهم كثير من المعارض
الله يعطيهم العافية، حجم التسويق اللي يتم لمملكتنا
صراحة شيء نرفع له القبعة، بشكل ممتاز واحترافي
ويخدمون القطاع الخاص بأنهم يسوقون للوجهات
واحنا نسوي أكثر من حزمة
أحيانًا نسوي، وهم يتعاقدوا مع شركات أجنبية للتسويق لها
وهذا الشيء صاير
وعلى طاري الهيئات، ودي أغطي موضوع المشرعين
اللي تتعاملون معهم، هل فيه مشرعين الآن تضطرون تبيعون...
أبشر، ودي بس أكمل قصة تايلند، لو تسمح لي بنص دقيقة
بدأنا العملية مع تايلند، وقتها أذكر وقعنا مع وزير السياحة التايلندي
كان موجود في الرياض، ووقعنا معه
يوم وقعنا معه؛ بدأنا في الحملة
في آخر السنة، بعد يمكن شهور كان جاي للسعودية مرة ثانية
فوقتها سأل، قال وين شركته «المسافر»؟
فكنت أذكر موجود على الطاولة
فكان هو موجود وموجود مؤثرين من كبرى الشركات
كذا الخطوط السعودية
وعرضوا أعداد المسافرين لتايلند
كان عدد المسافرين ذاك الوقت، من أول بداية السماح إلى نهايته
تقريبًا حدود 89 ألف شخص، 39 ألف شخص عن طريق «المسافر»
تتكلم عن حدود 45% من النسبة، هذا يعتبر شيء جدًّا ممتاز
يخلي هيئات السياحة العالمية تثق فينا
ولا جاءت الثقة هذه إلا من خلال القدرة الرقمية
الأنظمة الموجودة عندي، الفهم الموجود
وكذلك الشيء الموجود عندنا
خبرة مع مجموعة لها أربعين سنة في السوق
وعندنا عقلية ريادة أعمال بدأت في 2012
تزامن هذا مع رؤية 2030، تزامن هذا مع مجلس الإدارة
والرئاسة التنفيذية الموجودة، اللي خدمت الموضوع بشكل مرة كبير
هذا اللي خلّى الثقة هذه موجودة
فاليوم أي واحد بيدخل أي مجال
لازم تعرف أيش النقاط القوة اللي تدعم فيها شريكك
ما في أحد ينجح لحاله
لازم الشريك اللي بيمكّنك يعرف أيش نقاط القوة عندك
اليوم، الحمدلله، احنا حصتنا السوقية في الطيران
مقارنةً بشركات السفر والسياحة، آخر إحصائية 71%
ما شاء الله
طلّع الخطوط السعودية، أتكلم مو مع الخطوط
احنا مع الشركات السفر والسياحة الموجودة، احنا حصتنا 71%
في المقابل صعب تحسبها في الفنادق
بس أعطيك مثال حق تايلند
احنا نشوف كم عدد اللي سافروا عن طريقنا، كم حجزوا فنادق
كانوا تقريبًا حدود 39 ألف مقارنةً بـ 89 ألف من تايلند
المشرعين الآن
نعم
من المشرعين اللي تضطرون تتبعون ارشاداتهم بشكل عام؟
على مستوى المجموعة أو من شركة «المسافر»
طبعًا أكيد وزارة السياحة
ناخذ منها الرخصة الأساسية لبيع السفر والسياحة
كذلك السياحة الوافدة اللي هي السياحة الداخلية
شركة «اكتشف السعودية» ناخذ رخصة أننا ننظم رحلات
رخصة نقل، كذلك موضوع نروّج السيارات عن طريق...
لا، كل واحد لها رخصة ونسوي نظام جديد
فعندنا وزارة السياحة، عندنا الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
من ناحية إذا فيها أي نظام جديد أو وجهة جديدة
يحتاجون نسوّق لها، لازم يكون فيه مواءمة معهم بشكل مرة كبير
فيه قطاع الحج والعمرة، عندنا وزارة الحج والعمرة
الهيئة العامة للطيران المدني إذا كان عندنا...
لأن احنا وكلاء لكثير من شركات الطيران العالمية الموجودة
مثلًا طيران «الخليج» احنا وكلاءه في السعودية
الخطوط الفلبينية احنا وكلاءهم
فأي مبيعات لهم موظفين، وهم موظفين عندنا
فاحنا اللي ندير طيرانهم هنا
فهذا طبعًا يكون مع هيئة الطيران المدني
بالإضافة طبعًا نعمل بحكم السياحة الداخلية
والحراك الموجود في السياحة والنمو فيها
الهيئة الملكية لـ«العُلا» نشتغل معهم بشكل مرة كبير
هيئة تطوير بوابة «الدرعية» نشتغل معهم بشكل مرة كبير
بس هذولي يمكن عندهم فرص إضافية
فرص إضافية
قصدي للتشريع، مثل وزارة السياحة
وزارة السياحة والهيئة السعودية للسياحة وكذلك...
وزارة السياحة تروح لها إذا بتشتغل بأي نشاط له علاقة بالسياحة صح؟
صحيح، تاخذ رخصة نعم
الهيئة السعودية للسياحة متى تروح لها؟
الهيئة السعودية للسياحة إذا عندهم وجهة جديدة
يحتاجونك أن تكون مرخص
هذا كله عن طريق الوزارة
بس الهيئة هي اللي تعطينا المعلومة، أن هذه الوجهة نبغى نسوق لها
فلازم تكون تشتغل معهم بشكل مرة كبير
ما ينفع تقول لا أنا خلاص، ماخذ رخصة من السياحة بشتغل لحالي
لازم تكون يعرفونك وتعرفوهم
والحج والعمرة برضه لها رخصة ثانية؟
الحج والعمرة نعم لها رخص منفصلة
غير رخصة السياحة
فكل واحد يشتغل فيها، وكل رخصة لها متطلبات
وفيه تشريعات معينة لازم تلتزم فيها
تشريعات معينة، وإذا فيه مخالفات معينة لازم تُتبع لها
وطبعًا اليوم فيه دعم صاير، مو من جهة تشريعية
من جهة أن فيه وزارة الاستثمار تقود حراك كبير جدًّا
جعل الشركات السعودية أن تصير عالمية
أو كذلك استقطاب شركات عالمية أنها تشتغل في السعودية
من خلال شركات مع شركات سعودية. فسوينا هذا الشيء
هنا فيه نقطة مهمة، دخلنا على المحور الثاني حق المنافسين
ممكن مرتبط برضه في مدخل موضوع التشريعات
أتصور ناس بكل صراحة مثل «بوكينق» «هوتيلز»
المنصات العالمية اللي الناس يستخدموها
مو ملزومين يتبعون أي شيء من التشريعات هذه
صحيح
مو لازم يطلعون رخصة، مو لازم يسوون ولا شيء
ذكرنا عن موضوع خدمة العملاء، مو لازم يسعودون خدمة العملاء
فوزارة الموارد البشرية ما راح تلزمهم، بينما تلزمكم أنتم
نعم
أيش وضعهم؟
كيف تنافس واحد مثل هذا؟ يشتغل يسوي أي شيء يبغاه
بينما أنت والمنافسين المحليين ملزومين
أن تطلعون الرخص، وتلتزمون في التشريعات وتشتغلون ضمن قيود
طبعًا لمصلحة البلد أكيد
بس ذولي برّا النطاق
صحيح، هذه صراحة تم فيها النقاش وقُبلت بصدر رحب
من قِبل وزارة السياحة وكذلك وزارة الاستثمار
خلني أقول لك أيش الموضوع، اليوم وزارة السياحة
مثلًا لو أي مسافر سعودي حجز عن طريق منصة «المسافر»
ووصل لأي بلد في السعودية أو خارج السعودية
صار عنده مشكلة في الحجز، قد كذا المشاكل اللي تصير
أنه يصير المورد... أو مثلًا يبغى يلغي حجزه وهو حجزه غير مسترجع
ويكلم الفندق، ويقول أنا بوافق لك، بس كلمهم
فيه شغلات تصير بنتكلم فيها
فهو أيش يسوي؟ يكلم وزارة السياحة
فيه رقم للشكاوى، يقول أنا عندي مشكلة في شركة «المسافر» ويكلمونا
ونشرح لهم كل شيء
واحنا ملتزمين، وبالعكس نحترم الأنظمة وملتزمين فيها
في المقابل لو حجز عن طريق أي منصة عالمية
وصار له أي مشكلة، مالك قبيلي عندي
فما يقدر يتكلم مع أحد، يحاول يتكلم مع الشركة، يحاولون لهذا الموضوع
صار فيه ممارسات في دول أخرى
لتمكين المستثمر الوطني أو المحلي مثل شركة «المسافر» وغيرها
كيف أنهم يخدمون، يكون فيه عدل في هذا الموضوع
فشرطوا على الشركات العالمية، فيه تجربة في تركيا
شرطوا على «بوكينق» مثلًا
ما تقدر تمارس أعمالك، ما أقدر أفعّل منصتك من خلال الموضوع
يسوي عليها حماية
إلا أنك تفتح مكتب في تركيا وتخدم الفنادق
وفعلًا سوى هذا الشيء
فاحنا نفهمهم الموضوع
فيه طلب أن نحاول نخدم السوق السعودي
في المقابل وزارة الاستثمار قاعدة تدعمنا، الله يعطيها العافية
للانطلاقة العالمية
لهذا السبب، الحمدلله، فتحنا مكتب في جاكرتا
فتحنا مكتب في الكويت، عندنا موظفين في الكويت
عندنا موظفين في الإمارات، عندنا موظفين في مصر
عندنا موظفين في الأردن
استهداف الأسواق الثانية هذه ما فيها مشكلة
لا، بس الفتح هذا أكون أتبع للأنظمة في ذيك البلد أحيانًا
مثلًا سوق جاكرتا، لازم أفهم نظام جاكرتا
وعندي توقيع مع محامي وعندي تكاليف عشان أنطلق للعالمية
أنا معك، وجهة نظري وقد تخفاني بعض المعلومات ما أدري عنها
أعتقد من غير العادل سواءً لكم، لـ«فلاي أكيد» «قادرينق»
لكل الناس اللي يشتغلون في القطاع هذا محليًّا هنا
أنهم يشتغلون تحت التنظيمات هذه
سواءً من وزارة الالموارد بشرية، سواءً من وزارة السياحة
ومن أي جهة تنظيمية تنظم عملهم
أنهم يلتزمون فيها، بينما فيه جهة أخرى أجنبية تشتغل بأريحية
تسوي اللي تبيه، أنا مستفيد منها واحجز من خلالها
ولا ودي الحل كذا تقفل عليهم
لا، ما بيتقفل، بل صراحة اليوم، اللهم لك الحمد
أعتقد المملكة العربية السعودية منفتحة على العالم
ترحب بأي مستثمر يقدم أي خدمة
وبالعكس، ودي أوضح نقطة
أن القطاع السياحي، مع أن لي خمس سنوات في القطاع
ولكن مجال مرة جميل، فيه تقاطع مع الكثير من المجالات
ففيه فرص مرة كبيرة، قد ما يجون لاعبين في السوق، السوق مرة كبير
بس طالما يمشون بنفس التشريع
فاللي أقصده، تم رفع هذا الموضوع لوزارة السياحة
وجلسنا في ورشة عمل معهم
فيها كثير من التحديات اللي تواجه المستثمرين المحليين
حتى وزعوا استفتاء يطلبون كل المعلومات المطلوبة
وأعتقد أن فيه ترتيب لهذا الموضوع
لمحاولة العدل وتمكين المستثمر المحلي مثل المستثمر العالمي
والحين المشاكل اللي تواجهونها مع العملاء بشكل عام
أيش سياسة التعوضات عندكم، هل تحملها على المورد؟
وللا أنك أنت تتحمل قيمة التعويض؟
احنا طبعًا أهم علينا أن العميل يكون مرتاح وراضي
وتعرف في كل مجال، نفس مجال السفر والسياحة
أي مجال إذا كثروا فيه الوسطاء
كل ما صار فيه مخاطرة كبيرة أن ترضي العميل بشكل كبير
بس احنا مستوى الرضا عندنا من خلال قياساتنا اليومية؛ جدًّا عالي
وهذا لا يعني أن ما فيه مجال للتطوير كبير في تجربة العميل
وإرضاء العميل، ولكن في نظام في وزارة السياحة لإرضاء العميل
احنا مستمرين معه
طبعًا الشروط والأحكام في حجوزاتنا هي جدًّا واضحة
وفيه عندنا أكثر من مجال
مثلًا أقول لك من المشاكل اللي دائمًا تجينا
أن الحجز دائمًا لما يكون غير مسترد، وغير قابل للتعديل؛ يكون أرخص
لما يكون قابل للتعديل؛ يكون أغلى
وهذا طبيعة الموردين أو نفس الفنادق
فيه كثير من الناس يكون عنده حجزه غير قابل للاسترداد
ثم يصير عنده ظرف معين، يقول أبغى أرجّع
أحيانًا يكون بيننا وبينهم أكثر من مورد
أو مورد والمورد ماخذ من مورد آخر، وأحيانًا يكون فيه فندق
فيجي مورد يقول خلاص الحجز غير قابل للاسترداد، وهذه شروط وأحكام
العميل يكلم الفندق، الفندق يقول أنا بالنسبة لي عادي
ما عندي مشكلة، بس لو تجيني موافقة
فندخل أحيانًا إشكاليات
يطلع شكلك شين كذا
شوي إشكاليات، وهذه وحدة من التحديات الموجودة في القطاع
ولكن احنا نحاول أن نثقف عملاءنا
معناته موضوع احجز الآن، احنا اليوم ما زلنا موجودين
تقدر تحجز الآن وتدفع بعدين، موجود هذا الموضوع
كذلك موضوع أن عندنا علاقة جدًّا ممتازة
سوينا كثير من الإجراءات في نفس هذا الموضوع
والحمد لله، ساعدنا فيه عملاءنا
ولكن بشكل مرة كبير يكون هذا تحدي عندنا
في تعاملنا مع عملاءنا مقارنةً بأي شركة عالمية
والشركات المحلية من اللي تصنفونهم منافسين بالنسبة لكم؟
شوف، السوق مرة كبير، ولكن مثل ما قلت لك
حصتنا في السوق فقط في الطيران 71%
السوق مرة كبير من ناحية أنه يستوعب أكثر من شيء
دائمًا عملاءنا يقارنون بيننا وبين «بوكينق» من ناحية التجربة
وكذلك حتى الفنادق العالمية لما يجون للسعودية
لما نتكلم معهم، الحمد لله، علاقتنا معهم جدًّا ممتازة
وشايفين أن احنا أقدر أقول البطل الوطني اللي يقود
قطاع السفر والسياحة في القطاع الخاص في السعودية
أنا، إن شاء الله، بعد هذه الحلقة بحاول
أنا ما بقول «المسافر» بس بقول بدائل المحلية
أبد، وأنا فعلًا أعني هذه الكلمة
المجال السياحي، قطاع السفر والسياحة
قطاع مرة كبير، وفيه ميزة أنه يتقاطع مع مجالات كثيرة
يتقاطع مع قطاع التجزئة، يتقاطع مع السيارات
سواءً تأجير السيارات، وللا السيارات بسواقين، وللا باصات
يتقاطع مع الطيران
التجزئة، شلون يتقاطع معه؟
في المطار مثلًا أفتح لي محل، أبيع هدايا تذاكرية
أبيع هذه الأشياء الموجودة
فأذكر فيه في تجربة «المسافر» فيه أشياء كثيرة تقدر
مو بشرط أنك تنافس في هذا الموضوع، إذا كان خلاص هذا الموضوع
ولكن تشوف تجربة العميل، من أول ما تبدأ الين تنتهي
فيه تقاطعات كبيرة مع القطاع السياحي
تقدر تدخل فيها بشكل كبير
خصوصًا في الاستثمار اللي تسوية المملكة العربية السعودية
في قطاع السياحة الداخلية، واستقطاب الناس من برّا
سواءً في مجال السياحة الدينية أو السياحة الداخلية
التحديات لو بنمر عليها بشكل عام
اللي أعرفه أن هوامش الربح قليلة في القطاع ذا
صحيح
تقدر تتكلم كم تقريبًا؟
طبعًا مثل ما قلنا، احنا نبيع كرسي طيارة وغرفة فندق
متاحة لعشرة آلاف واحد يقدر يبيعها
متوسط أرباح الطيران هي تقريبًا حدود 4%
في المقابل، احنا عندنا مؤشر أساسي جدًّا
يزيد وينقص على حسب العرض والطلب
على حسب العرض والطلب
وعلى حسب اتفاقيتك مع ...
أحيانًا يقولك خطوط طيران المسار هذا
من مثلًا الرياض إلى الدولة الفلانية؛ عندي فيه مشكلة
بعطيك عمولة زيادة، قد ما تقدر تسوّق له
فنحاول احنا نسويه، وناخد منه هوامش أكثر
في المقابل، احنا دائمًا عندنا مؤشر اللي هو مبيعات غير الطيران
اللي هي الفنادق، تأجير السيارات
هذا كل وحدة كم تطلع تقريبًا، كمتوسط؟
متوسط من 12% - 15%
في الفنادق وفي السيارات؟
بالضبط. فقد ما تقدر
اليوم كثير من شركات السفر والسياحة 90% من مبيعاتهم طيران
احنا اليوم، الحمد لله، وصلنا لمرحلة تقريبًا 65% - 35%
65 طيران 35% ...
ما تبيها تسيطر على مبيعاتك؛ عشان ما يصير الهوامش أقل
بالضبط، قد ما تقدر تكّثر من مبيعات غير الطيران
قد ما يكون عندك فرصة ممتازة أنك ترفع الربحية
فالمشكلة بس في مبيعات الطيران؟
الهوامش فيها قليلة جدًّا، ولكنها هي المحرك الأساسي للسفر
أول ما يحجز وجهة، لازم يحجز مع فندق، بعدين لازم يحجز مع سيارة
بالضبط، وقد ما تقدر تحط خدمات زيادة؛ قد ما أنك تقدر...
مثل كثير من المطاعم، تلقى عنده وجبة أساسية
قد يكون ما فيه هوامش
تبغى كوكيز؟
بالضبط، كوكيز وللا آيسكريم، هذه هي
كنا نسولف قبل، أذكر زمان أول مرة تقابلنا
طريناها بشكل سريع، بس ما تعمقنا فيها
كنت تقول لي تجربة السوق المصري في السياحة
أنضج بكثير من عندنا، وأن فيه أشياء كثيرة ناقصة عندنا
مقارنة بالسوق المصري
مو بالسوق المصري بالذات
أو خلنا نقول السياحة في مصر
السياحة في مصر أو السياحة في العالم
مثلًا لو بتروح بكرة لإسطنبول، أنتم وفد عددكم خمسين شخص
تقدر مباشرة تلقى مرشدين سياحيين
مثلًا اليوم ما عندنا وفرة في المرشدين السياحيين
وهذه فرصة لأي شاب سعودي، أن يأخذ رخصة مرشد سياحي
اللي تعتمد من قِبل وزارة السياحة والهيئة السعودية للسياحية
ياخذها بحيث يكون مرشد سياحي
هذه فيها دخل إضافي جدًّا ممتاز
لو أنك تمارس وظيفتك، تقدر تأخذ الرخصة هذه
إذا أخذ الرخصة، هل مباشرة تصيرون تعرفون أن هذا متوفر؟
نعم، أدخل على الجمعية السعودية للسياحة
موجود فيه كل شيء وخلاص
فما يحتاج يسوّق لنفسه
هو جيد أن يروح يسوّق نفسه ويروح للشركات
يقول هذا رقمي، وأقدر أتعامل معكم كعمل حر
أيش اللي أقصد عن موضوع النضج
فيه دول كثيرة سابقتنا في السياحة
من ناحية التعامل مع السواح قد لا يعني بالضرورة أنهم أكفأ
من ناحية جودة الخدمة، ولكن في وفرة للعاملين في القطاع السياحي
سواءً كعمليات استقبال وتوديع، وللا مرشدين سياحيين
أو كذلك الأشياء الداعمة للسياحة
السيارات، الفنادق، مكتب «إرشاد العملاء» اللي موجود
دائمًا في فنادق في السعودية فيه كاونتر لـ «إرشاد العملاء»
ما عمري استخدمته
غير مفعل بشكل كبير
اليوم احنا قاعدين نستهدفهم للسياحة الداخلية
نروح ونقول مجموعتنا إذا جاكم ناس من برّا السعودية
وجاء سألك توّني واصل الرياض، أيش أسوي؟
قل له ترى فيه عندنا جولات موجودة في الرياض
فيه جولات موجودة في جدة
أقدر أوديك «شقراء» و«أشيقر» تشوف المدينة التاريخية وترجع
ومستقبلًا نقدر نوديك لنهاية العالم وترجع
فهذا الشيء مفعّل مثلًا في كثير من البلدان
ذكرت مصر، ذكرت تركيا، ذكرت في جنوب أفريقيا
موجودة فيها بشكل مرة كبير
احنا بدأنا في 2015 وللا «المسافر» من قبل
التعامل مع أنظمة الطيران، ووجود طاقات موجودة
خلانا نستثمر كثير في الأسواق هذه
بالإضافة اليوم لاستثمارنا
أنت زرتنا في الشركة، وشفت اليوم عندنا مركز اتصال مرة كبير
عندنا كذلك فريق لخدمة العملاء
عندنا اليوم عدد موظفين الشركة تقريبًا حدود 2500 شخص
وفيه برضه المشاريع كبيرة عندنا في السعودية
«نيوم» البحر الأحمر، «العُلا»
هذه أيش تتوقع الفرص اللي توفرها
سواءً لرواد الأعمال، مرشدين سياحيين وغيرهم؟
أعتقد، إن شاء الله، من اليوم احنا قاعدين نعيشها
والسنوات القادمة بنعيش تجربة جدًّا ثرية
من ناحية التنوع الموجود في المحتوى المحلي السياحي
تبي بحر وغوص واستجمام؛ عندك البحر الأحمر
إذا تبغى سياحة تراثية أو سياحة تاريخية
ولكن تجربة ثرية جدًّا؛ تقدر تروح لـ«العُلا»
تبغى تعرف الإرث التاريخي للمملكة؛ عندك «الدرعية»
عندك المشاريع الموجودة في الرياض كترفيه
عندنا «القدية» بالأشياء اللي شفناها عنا
«نيوم» كمدينة مستقبلية بتخاطب العالم بشكل مرة كبير
قبل يومين أُعلن عن قمم «السودة»
كمشروع بيكون جدًّا ثري وممتاز، بحكم أن عندنا الصيف
بالإضافة بتكون فيه تجربة كبيرة جدًّا، حتى في الشتاء في جنوب المملكة
فأعتقد أن التنوع هذا بيخدم شركات السياحة بشكل كبير
اليوم احنا بحكم شراكاتنا وتجربتنا مع الهيئة الملكية لـ«العُلا»
تجربتنا مع كثير من الشركات الموجودة
عندنا اليوم تعاون مع شركة البحر الأحمر، للتسويق لفنادقهم
سواءً من خلال الشركات العالمية
اللي بتفتح فنادق داخل المدن هذه
أو من خلال تفعيل بعض التجارب
شركة البحر الأحمر أيش تسوي؟
شركة البحر الأحمر اللي تمتلك المشروع
هي مملوكة لصندوق الاستثمارات العامة
بيكون عندهم تقريبًا أكثر من اثنين وعشرين منتجع
موجود في مدينة البحر الأحمر
فهذه أكيد احنا بنسوّق معهم، بنفعّل، بنسوي أكثر من حزمة
سواءً للسياحة الوافدة أو للسياحة المحلية
بدأنا في النقاش معهم بشكل كبير
حتى اليوم «سندالة» إن شاء الله، بتبدأ في بداية 2024 في الربع الأول
أيش هي؟
بدأنا في النقاش
«سندالة» هذه أحد الجزر، هي أول مشاريع «نيوم»
خلاص بتبدأ، إن شاء الله، التشغيل في الربع الأول في 2024
وهذه أيش بتحتاج؟
احنا نفعّل أكثر من حزمة معهم، نحجز الفنادق عندهم
إذا فيه مثلًا عمليات أرضية نقدر نسويها
من ناحية الاستقبال والتوديع، خدمات الترتيب
خدمات الاستقبال وكذلك النقل نقدر نسويها معهم
وبدأنا في النقاش معهم، وفيه مجال كبير
لدخول أي رائد أعمال مثل ما قلت، أو أي واحد مستثمر
يقدر يدخل معهم، ويفعّل كثير من الخدمات
أنا أحسكم، ما شاء الله، دخلتوا في كل شيء
وين رايحين مستقبلًا؟
الحمد لله، تجربة «المسافر» بدأت من منصة
موجودة في وسائل التواصل
واليوم تطورت أنها شركة فيها تنوع كبير
وتخدم جميع قطاعات السفر والسياحة
سواءً سفر الأفراد أو سفر قطاع الحكومة والشركات
كذلك شركة السياحة الداخلية أو الحج والعمرة
بالإضافة أنت ذكرت موضوع الشاليهات، الحمدلله، تجربتنا جدًّا ممتازة
اليوم لما تحجز شاليه، أنت تشوف الشاليه بشكل كامل 360
تشوفه 360 درجة، كأنك تدخل فيه، مو أن الصور بس تنحط
فهذا حرصنا أن يكون فيه تجربة تنافسية تخلينا نتميّز عن غيرنا
البطاقة البنكية
كيف؟
بطاقة بنكية مثل حق «الفرسان»
بتسمع أخبار حلوة، إن شاء الله، قريبًا
في الإضافة نعمل على منصة أعلنا عنها
اسمها شركة «المسافر للأنشطة»
كانت هذه بالتعاون مع شركة عالمية اسمها «كلوك»
موجودة في سوق آسيا وأوربا
«كلوك» هي منصة للأنشطة في العالم
مثلًا وصلت لماليزيا، تدخل على «كلوك»
تقول أنا موجود في «كوالالمبور» يطلع لك منظمي الرحلات
عندهم أنشطة كثيرة، واللي عنده جولة في ماليزيا
اللي عنده يروح المشي الجبلي في جبل
اللي عنده جولة بخيول
أي واحد منظم رحلات، يقدر يحط أنشطته إذا موجودة هنا في المنصة
وتقدر تحجزها أونلاين
شفنا اليوم في السوق السعودي
فيه حاجة لمثل هذا النوع من المنصة
ذكرت لك موضوع «إرشاد العملاء» في الكونترات الموجودة في الفنادق
أو أي واحد بيزور السعودية أو كذلك السعوديين
أنت اليوم لما تروح لحائل وللا الجوف
ترى فيه شباب من أهل المنطقة، وبنات من أهل المنطقة
عندهم تجارب ممتازة، وشفناها
واحد فاتح مزرعته يسوي لك تجربة
أنك تطبخ معهم، ثم تاكلون، ثم تمشون
هذه التجربة يقدر يسويها ويحطها في «المسافر للأنشطة»
وتكون سوق أو متجر لكل جميع الأنشطة الموجودة في السعودية
الحمد لله، بوركت من قِبل الهيئة السعودية للسياحة
وإن شاء الله، نتوقع تدشينها في الشهر القادم
وهذه بتكون فيها، إن شاء الله، خدمة لقطاع السياحة بشكل مرة كبير
بحيث أن الواحد يقدر يشتري أي تجربة في السعودية
ما أدري أنت يا مشهور، هل رحت مثلًا لـ«أملج»
«أملج» البحر فيها مرة جميلة
أنا أسوأ واحد تكلمني بالسياحة الداخلية ترى
ما السبب؟
أنا حدي أبها، كان رحت لها مرة واحدة وشغل
لأنها أعتقد للأسف صورة نمطية مرتبطة عند كثير من الناس
وقد تكون واقع، ما أعرف
بس مرتبطة بالسعر الغالي
مرتبطة أني إذا بصرف داخل السعودية
بصرف غالبًا أكثر من لو بصرف في أوربا
صحيح، اليوم، الحمدلله، مع الوفرة الموجودة
وكثير من مقدمين الخدمات المحليين، صار فيه منافسة
اليوم بدأت تقل الأسعار، واليوم مقبلين على تطور مرة كبير
ولكن فعلًا فيه مجال للتطوير بشكل مرة كبير
أبها صراحة تجربتي رحت لها بعز الصيف
براد كانت درجة الحرارة الظاهر 22، زمان ذا الكلام
كانت تجربة جميلة جدًّا، والناس اللي هناك أجمل
ناس مضيافين، تحس أنك ملك وأنت معهم
أنا أذكر في مرة من المرات، كان عندي رحلة عمل
ولكن هدفها أننا نشوف أماكن سياحية، فكانت ترفيه مع عمل
رحنا ثلاثة أيام للمنطقة الجنوبية، ولكن زرنا فيها ثلاثة مدن
زرنا نجران وجيزان و«فرسان» وكذلك أبها، أربع مدن
الإرث والمحتوى الثقافي والجغرافي وكذلك الطقس
نوعية الأكل، نوعية الناس، وعاداتهم؛ كل بلد مختلفة عن الثانية
وكل وحدة أجمل من الثانية
الأكل في جيزان يختلف عن الأكل في أبها
«رجال ألمع» أنت الحين في أبها، الجو مرة بارد
تنزل مع العقبة توصل لـ«رجال ألمع» الجو مره دافئ
تنزل شوي لجيزان، في الصيف درجة حرارة 18 في أبها
في جيزان درجة الحرارة 45
وقتها رحنا لـ«فرسان» من أجمل البحار اللي شفتها
ما يحتاج حتى تركب قارب وتروح
أنت في البحر تغوص شوي بالنظارة؛ تشوف الشعب المرجانية عندك
ما بالك في البحار اللي ما لُمست في البحر الأحمر
اللي أنا قاعد أتطور
صار لي تجربة ممتازة جدًّا
يمكن أنا لفيت السعودية بشكل مرة كبير
فيه عندي هذا الشغف، في المقابل بحكم طبيعة العمل
الجوف فيها أكبر مزرعة زيتون في العالم
أكبر بحيرة صناعية في العالم
موجودة في «دومة الجندل» اللي هي في الجوف
رحتها جميلة جدًّا بشكل مختلف
بالعكس تتعجب من الطبيعة الموجودة
فإذا صار فيها خدمات، السكان المحليين استغلوا الفرصة
تزامن هذا الشيء أنهم يسوون أكثر من حزمة لهم في «المسافر للأنشطة»
وللا الهيئة السعودية للسياحة سوّقت لهذا الموضوع
أعتقد فيه مجال للتطور بشكل كبير الفترة القادمة
من الأشياء اللي سويناها كذلك وكان فيها تجربة ممتازة
والاستفادة من المصادر الموجودة عندك
احنا تعرف استثمرنا كثير في التقنية
يمكن أنت سافرت عن طريق سفر حكومي
كان فيه مصطلح موجود جدًّا اسمه أمر إركاب
اليوم التجربة في شركة «المسافر أعمال»
اللي هي الشركة الخاصة بخدمة القطاع الحكومي والشركات
ومن أكبر العملاء عندنا اللي هي وزارة الصحة
جميع التجربة هي أونلاين
يصدر أمر الإركاب من خلال المنصة
ربطنا مع قسم الموارد البشرية الموجود في الشركة أو في الوزارة
بحيث مثلًا لا سمح الله أنت مريض
واليوم الدولة، اللهم لك الحمد، متكفلة بعلاج جميع الناس داخل السعودية
فقد يكون يضطر أن يسافر إلى الرياض
ياخذ مثلًا موعد معين في أي مستشفى
فأول ما يصدر له أمر الإركاب، تجي رسالة من «المسافر»
اصدر لك أمر إركاب، يدخل يبحث، يجيه محرك البحث
مثلًا إذا هو جاي من «القريات»
من «القريات» إلى الرياض فقط
ما يطلع له محركات البحث الثانية
فتجيه الرحلات هذه، يصدّر تذكرته
تروح إلى الموافقة من خلال نظام أونلاين
تجيه تذكرته على إيميله
من أول لازم يأخذ أمر إركاب، يروح لجهة حكومية
ثم بعدين يصدّر التذكرة من خلال متعهد السفر الموجود
والورقة هذه إذا ضاعت من متعهد السفر
ما يقدر ياخد فلوسه، أنا كمستثمر
اليوم من خلال النظام هذا؛ تم فيه إحداث نقلة
في هذا القطاع بشكل مرة كبير
عاد ما تكلمنا كثير بتفاصيل الحكومة والشركات
نعم ولكن ليش أنا أقول هذا الكلام مشهور
اليوم فيه مجال كبير للتطوير
وفيه مجال كبير لرفع مستوى الخدمة في قطاعات كثيرة للسياحة
اللي أحب أقوله، مجال السفر والسياحة مجال مرة كبير
مع التطور اللي صاير اليوم في المملكة العربية السعودية
في تطوير القطاع السياحي وقطاع السفر والطيران
أعتقد فيه مجال كبير للسعودة
اليوم عندنا خطوط السعودية لاعب رئيسي في السوق
عندنا طيران «ناس» عندنا طيران «أديل» للقطاع الداخلي
عندنا طيران «الرياض» خلاص أُعلن عنه بيبدأ
بالإضافة لكثير من خطوط الطيران العالمية
اليوم تعتبر السعودية وجهة أساسية
بسبب وجود الحرمين الشريفين
وكذلك التفعيل السياحي اللي صاير
من قِبل الهيئة السعودية للسياحة للتسويق للسعودية بشكل مرة كبير
خطوط السعودية عاد راعين البرنامج وحبايبي
تدري توني اكتشف هذا الشيء، يمكن غبني قبل فترة
توني اكتشف أن الأميال اللي تاخذها على الخطوط السعودية
طريقة صرف النقاط هي نقاط ثابتة، ما تتغير مثل الأسعار
مثلًا وجهة داخلية 500 نقطة، وفي أي وقت
صحيح
وأنا كنت أول أحسب أنها تتغير
وأقول أيش الفايدة الناس يطلعون بطاقات؟!
أنت ما كان عندك بطاقة؟
لا، كنت أسجّل الأميال حقتي، بس ما كنت أشوف جدوى
قاعد أروج الحين على الخطوط السعودية، بس يستاهلون
ما كنت أشوف جدوى أني أطلع بطاقة «الفرسان»
اللي طلعتها مؤخرًا الحين
لأني أحسب النقاط ذي، ما تقدر تقيّمها
مو شرط عن طريق بطاقة «الفرسان»
إذا اشتريت عن طريق «المسافر»
تقدر تحوّل مشترياتك إلى نقاط، فعادي
في «الفرسان»؟
في «الفرسان»
شبيّح ترى رعاتنا
إيه في «الفرسان» شراكاتنا معهم استراتيجية
وشغالين معهم بشكل مرة كبير
يصير آخذ نقاط عندكم وعندهم؟
تاخذ نقاط في «الفرسان» احنا ما عندنا نقاط
نقاطنا من خلال «قطاف» أو من خلال «الفرسان»
أو أنه مبلغ يودع لك في محفظتك في المساعدة
نفس النقاط اللي هم بيعطون إياها مباشرة
نعم
كويس، كذا أقدر أجرب
نعم، جرّب بالعكس ونسعد
يعطيك العافية أخوي فهد
الله يحييك
فيه نقاط ويمكن فيه أشياء كثير ما غطيناها
لكن هذا يمكن يعطي فرصة
لاستضافة عدة أشخاص في قطاع السياحة
لأنه قطاع ضخم جدًّا
فيه تفاصيل كثيرة، احنا بنكون غطينا الموضوع بشكل أفقي
ما دخلنا يمكن بالعمق
بس لعلها كل حلقة هذه مع ضيف آخر
نبدأ نتعمق في القطاعات المختلفة
لكن أثريتنا صراحة بشكل كبير في القطاع هذا
الله يحييك
يعطيك ألف عافية
الله يعافيك ويبقيك، وبالعكس والله هذه فرصة زينة
وأنا من خلال هذا المكان، أتشكر من جميع أخواني وأخواتي
الموجودين في شركة «المسافر»
على قدمٍ وساق يحاولون يقدمون منتجات وخدمات جدًّا ممتازة
في جميع شركات المجموعة والشركة
أتشكر من مجلس الإدارة، الرئيس التنفيذي، جميع العاملين
كلهم حريصين لتقديم خدمة لائقة باللاعب المحلي
اللي هو شركة «المسافر»
لشركة بدأت من شركة صفرية اليوم شركة بليونية
نطمح، أن شاء الله، نكبر ونكون لاعبين في السوق بشكل مرة كبير
أشكرك لهذا اللقاء
وإن شاء الله، نطمح أنك تكون أحد عملاءنا قريبًا
بإذن الله
ويمكن بعدين موظف، على الخصومات اللي سمعت تعطونها الموظفين
أبرك من ساعة
الله يعطيك العافية، تشرفت فيك
الله يحييك، يا أهلًا وسهلا، شكرًا
شكرًا لكم، وشكرًا لعبدالملك آل سعيد في إنتاج المحتوى
في التحرير مرام ضبيبان
في إدارة التصوير ياسر بن غانم
في الإضاءة عبدالمجيد عمر
في الهندسة الصوتية عبدالعزيز المزّي
في الإخراج الفني مجد الملّي ومساعده وسيم معين
وفي الإنتاج التنفيذي غيداء التميمي
هذا بودكاست سوالف بزنس
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع